We do,
um,
a couple of commercials and then we get
cracking because the commercials were on
right now.
So when the commercials start,
if you feel like talking,
you just go ahead.
It doesn't mean it.
No,
I'll do it.
I'll be respectful to you.
Doesn't matter.
Commercials.
Jim Jeffries.
I'm telling you.
You do whatever you want to do.
Everyone's allowed to chime in.
Fart on me.
Who is Tim Jeffries?
Just waved a fart on me.
I did.
I don't even know what I do these days.
I did that so solidly.
That sounds like something I would have
done.
So I'm going to.
I'm going to just apologize and you
don't even.
You just went on autopilot.
Auto Fart on you.
Pilot the podcast brought to you by the
flashlight.
That's our main number one sponsor.
Our first sponsor ever of all time.
Way Back in the day when we were just on
a laptop with Ustream snowflakes in the
background.
When they were black and white,
there was a flashlight.
That's when the date before the Avatar
or that not alien movie one.
They were just black and white.
We started when there was black and
white television stuff,
but fleshlight stopped blind prion.
It's true.
There was no black and white
televisions.
What are you talking about?
Like,
like back in the day there was black and
white TV and when we started with just
like we started winning was only black
and white,
you know,
black and white flashlights.
That's a terrible joke.
It wasn't.
It doesn't even make sense.
It doesn't even make me go back even
further and go.
We started the podcast with talkies.
It doesn't even make sense.
That's what it was silent.
That's when we were doing.
You're lying to these people.
They know you only been doing it for two
years.
Everybody knows.
No,
no,
no.
The flashlight like black and white.
It's just a flashlight joke.
It was not supposed to be really thought
about too.
Was it true?
There was more.
There was a bunch of different colors,
right?
No,
when we started,
I think it was just black and white
unless they had the alien one before
that,
but I don't think they did.
Didn't they have like zombies and shit?
No.
That happened on late recently.
Really?
Yeah,
so you have as a black and white,
so that's what your joke was.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
It was pretty good man.
Did you like it?
No,
I have.
I haven't even got it yet.
Somebody else is here.
I'm glad because you know if there's a
message boards out there,
there's 100 people right now.
The agreement.
Brian,
Brian's totally.
It totally made sense.
It was an excellent joke.
Fucking duking it out right now and some
internet forums over this.
Anyway,
it's a good product.
The fleshlight solid,
you know it's embarrassing shore,
but you know you're going to masturbate,
so just go get one.
Fuck it.
Try it.
It's good.
Use codenamed Rogan and you save 15
percent.
There you go.
To save you some money and joy,
it will also brought to you by
[inaudible] Dot Com,
o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplements,
new mood,
the serotonin boosting supplement,
and we have shroom,
tech,
sport and shroom,
immune,
all of them essentially.
Um,
except for I guess the shroom tech
wouldn't be necessarily thought of as a
nootropic,
but what they are with especially a
Alpha brain is,
is,
uh,
it's vitamins
for enhancing your cognitive function.
What does that mean?
The way it's explained to me is it
enhances your body's ability to produce
neurotransmitters and you feel,
feel better.
You feel clear.
I take it all the time.
I feel great and I noticed a difference
to you when I'm taking it.
And when I'm not taking it,
I,
I can tell 'em,
go to [inaudible] dot com for details.
Oh,
and it.
And uh,
use a code name,
Rogan and save 10 percent first 30
pills.
The first order you may get,
if anything,
it's a 100 percent money back guarantee.
So even if you eat it all,
you could take all the vitamins,
eat all 30 of them and go,
you know,
and I think this is shit.
Then you get your money back.
No one's trying to rip anybody off.
This is all stuff that I've used long
before I was ever associated with this
company and I'm a big believer in
vitamins.
So
go and check it out.
I'm playing footsies with his bitch
playing footsies with.
We needed more space.
Is What this is.
Is tables too small?
Accidental footsies will not be
tolerated.
Especially I'm barefoot.
I'm like one of the Abbott brothers
brothers in a music video.
I'm going to take off my shoe and sock
will be really gross.
Don't take off your shoes and socks.
Sometimes you fried steak dude.
You know every now and then you rock the
wrong shoes too many days in a row.
I slept with my shoes.
Don't last night.
So you might be right.
I heard you slept in your car,
is that correct?
Yeah,
I passed out in my car for a little
while.
You driving then passed out.
We just remember.
I just walked.
By the way.
That's so illegal.
You should never do that.
You should just get a hotel somewhere
because if you're asleep in your car and
you,
even if you have no intention of driving
drunk and have a cop knocks on your
door,
you're going to jail.
But what if you're in the backseat
garnered gel?
Really kind of sleeping a canton?
No,
no,
no.
What about all these comics that always
tell you that?
Like I was sleeping in my car the first
year,
they got lucky.
They were all doing something illegal.
Well,
no,
they're not
necessarily doing something illegal.
I mean,
you know,
I bet there's places you could park
where no one's going to care.
We can go to rest.
Stop.
Thiswhat restaurant scene is if you're
drunk,
if you're drunk and you're in your car,
if you're sleeping in your car,
they don't care that you had no
intention to drive drunk.
They still,
they're,
they're gonna.
They're gonna fucking arrest.
Yo.
If you're hammered or you're in your
car.
I,
I don't drink drive because I'm not a
citizen the day I am.
Yeah,
we haven't even started yet.
Go to [inaudible] dot com.
Learn everything,
details,
blah,
blah blah.
And in the code named Rogan,
save yourself 10 percent off or all
orders done.
Thank you very much.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the Great Jim,
Jefferies,
the ladies and gentlemen.
Um,
and this podcast unfortunately started
about 15 minutes ago and we just decided
to let you in on it now for the past 15
minutes.
Jim Jefferies and Brian have been
laughing up a storm.
You,
you silly bitches.
I feel like we've used all the best
stuff to be.
Yeah.
I feel like we,
we,
you know,
we got to a good.
It's like if you go to the gym and you
lift,
first thing you do is too heavy.
You can fuck up the rest of your
workout.
Right?
Brian?
Yeah.
Brian knows what's up.
Jim Jefferies,
I personal train.
Very occasionally I get personally
trained by a guy who gets very
disappointed in me.
Kenny Kane.
Oh yeah.
It was a comedian as well.
Oh,
he's a comedian slash personal fitness
guys.
Oh,
that's cool.
How do you become a personal fitness
guide?
You have to have as a degree in
kinesiology.
Dying.
No,
he trains lots of famous people,
so he must have something going on.
You just,
I guess I for me to be convinced,
but personal training is just,
it's just,
it.
It's only useful to lazy people.
You know what I mean,
because I give up really quickly.
It's just the guy.
I just need a person.
It could be a fat person staying there
going,
keep going,
come on,
come on.
You've got another one.
And you're like,
all right then.
Because if I'm by myself,
a very low threshold for any type of
activity really.
But you make yourself go to the gym,
like I don't want to be.
I don't want to be morbidly obese.
No.
My mother's a huge fat woman.
I have fat jeans.
I fight against that.
I don't want to be a fatty.
Yeah.
Will You keep it together?
You know,
I'm always on the brink,
but uh,
yeah,
it's tough to be disciplined,
you know?
It's tough to force yourself to do shit
that's not pleasant,
but you're very good at,
but you enjoy it.
Right?
I feel like
I need it.
I don't,
I don't like the way I function when I
don't work out.
I don't like the way I think.
I don't like the,
you know,
my,
my threshold threshold for getting
annoyed at things gets too high.
You know,
I'm two tents,
I think physically the way you
physically feel it affects the way you
interacted with people and I think you
almost have a duty,
you know,
to try to keep your shit in line at
least enough so that it's not fucking up
on you,
so you're annoyed all the time when
you're around people because that's what
a lot of like really cranky,
bitchy people.
You know what that is?
That's,
that's a person with a really unhappy
body that's an unhappy
I'm of the opinion that if you let
yourself go too much,
you do become a burden on others.
It's all right if you get my kids get
cancer or something like that.
I think in the more fat it's more
comfortable,
but there's some dudes where you see a
model in and
come on man,
you know someone's got to pull you aside
like you got this has got to stop.
How do you and not have anybody that
couldn't have talked some sense into you
it.
Well,
I guess the pool is just too strong,
man.
Now my mother is a huge woman.
How big a at a peak would have been over
300 pounds,
but also also bring in hoarding.
Oh No.
Is a condition.
That TV show I changed my fucking life,
man.
That's my childhood.
I was watching it like,
yeah,
borderline.
Oh my God.
But every single one of our bedrooms,
after we moved out,
me and my two brothers,
those bedrooms that would just fill up
with shit just.
But Jesus Christ.
Now,
when,
when you,
when you look back,
did you,
what did you think was going on when you
were a kid?
Um,
I just,
my mother called herself a collector.
You know how these people call
themselves collectors if they toward one
particular thing,
but it was,
it was porcelain dolls.
Creepy Victorian fucking dolls are all
around your hundreds and hundreds of
them just staring at you while you ever
do mushrooms and look at them.
Terrifying.
Oh my.
That would not be split.
There was one that used to scare me that
I'd had to put a towel over his head
every time I was watching TV.
Otherwise I couldn't.
Wow.
Be Comfortable with my grandmother.
Was it,
was that in those little paper weights
that were light look like Globes or
something?
Oh yeah,
everywhere.
When you look them in and some of those,
but also those big marble ones that it
looks like you've just had a huge
marble.
I've never understood the pipe white
market I've probably had in my life my
ab 10 pipe away.
I don't think I've had,
I've never had a bit where I like,
my paper has been so out of control.
I just shut windows.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm a window shutter.
I,
I see that as an easier fix than just
paper blowing everywhere or.
And plus there's so many outside,
like in your yard,
if you really needed something to wait
one polk one,
and if anything's one,
these people who,
who made just think that it's an actual
invention that will like,
we'll build an actual blast object with
a spindly thing in the middle.
Yeah.
And then everybody else was like,
Oh shit,
we got to get involved with that market.
Right?
God Damn.
I got to jump on that.
Global wonder.
I wonder if it's patented or patent.
Usually patented,
that's what we painted.
Is that how you would say it?
That's how I would say it,
but I still think that's the wrong way
to say it.
In my exit,
it was me speaking like a todd.
I don't think it was.
I don't think it was anything to do with
being Australian.
It's so bizarre
how similar Australians are two
Americans,
even though like,
you know,
you guys have a different accent,
the accents a little,
a little odd for us.
I think we're seeing more similar to the
British person you are as well.
But I mean it's,
it's amazing how you go there,
what I'm going by the way,
uh,
the way.
I mean and it's like you just could fit
right in the,
the accent notes after a day and that's
just what people sound like.
And it seems like you're in America.
Well,
I don't notice the American accent now
on anybody at all.
It's the only one I have to do an
audition and they make me do the
American accent that I'd get a bit
shitty with the whole thing.
Oh,
do they do that?
That you would make you change your
voice for that.
And like,
I fucked that one audition.
I got a couple of callbacks and then I
said the word,
uh,
I said,
I said I went to the zoo and I saw her
zebra.
I still said,
Whoa,
whoa.
He just said that.
I still said it in an American accent,
but with British phrasing and they
freaked the fuck out.
I need to hear more of this American
voice.
That was a creepy voice.
Dude.
Why?
Why is that so creepy?
What are we going to do that is creepy
as fuck you talking with an American
voice.
That is crazy.
Like I say,
I'm sort of anonymous advice.
I can't a lot on stage.
People always want me to say like when I
photos and it talking American right now
in my accent,
if I say it's,
it sounds great,
but even when I say count as an
American,
I've go,
oh,
well that's a bit harsh dude.
You sound like a totally different human
when you look at that fucking kid over
there.
Come on.
Never think that's Jim Jefferies.
There's no way.
I would think that's,
you know,
that's the thing is called me up.
That would freak me the fuck out.
I'm tell you right now.
Don't do that.
Just sound guy.
You know,
it doesn't sound.
I just want to speak to you very
quickly.
We have a few problems here right now.
It sounds vaguely fucked up.
Like you.
It doesn't sound right.
It sounds really good though.
It's so close to like a real person.
Like there's something affected about
Saint Joe.
I want to hear you.
And then that kind of like a fight.
It wasn't bad.
That was,
shall we say we don't,
we don't,
we don't.
I do more English like mine.
Mine's 50 slash 50 because I lived in
England for 10 years,
but we don't say the word.
We don't say the word shrimp.
Like Americans go pro and stripped.
We call them prawns,
right?
Paul Hogan does that fucking commercial
where he goes,
oh,
I'll throw another shrimp on the Barbie
for you like that.
Right.
And now that's synonymous with a
strange.
When that's not even a word,
we say I'm probably yelled at out at
American gigs,
but when I'm on stage going through the
shrimp thing,
I'm like,
what the fuck off man?
Isn't it weird how many like crazy
personalities have come out of
Australia?
Like the crocodile hunter about Hogan
Crocodile Dundee.
Diana?
Yeah,
and he lives around here somewhere.
Does it?
Kangaroo Jack.
They only did a couple of those
crocodile dundee.
So then they were done.
I would have thought that could have
been like some Indiana Jones type.
None.
I did the third.
The third one is appalling.
Third One's always straight to DVD.
Yeah,
and it's.
And it's like.
Because the whole idea was a crocodile.
Dundee went from Australia in the
outback of Australia to New York and
it's like,
what the fuck's he going to do?
This is such a different place so you
can survive out there,
but he can't survive here.
It's not for the first two films.
Then for the third film,
you think let's send him to another
country like Britain or somewhere else.
That's different.
It's Crocodile Dundee in La.
Now.
The thing is,
he's been living since the last
crocodile dundee film.
He's been living in New York for over a
decade and then he gets to la and he
doesn't know what's going on when it
gets too alarming for him.
Like where all these people wearing
sunglasses full.
This is weed.
She's.
These women's breasts are too big,
like it's not a great film and in the
end he becomes an animal trainer for the
movies and he foils a robbery and
actually now I look back.
It's a great field.
I didn't give it uninhibited chairs.
She was just the sheer ridiculousness.
Still with Lynda Kozlowski who he
married from the.
From the movie.
The thing is a Paul Hogan was married to
a real fat woman called Napoleon Hogan
who was just this big fat woman.
Right.
And he had five kids with her and then
he does the CROC,
which he had before.
He was famous.
Then he did Crocodile Dundee and he
started dating Lynda Kozlowski and the
Australian public.
We're like,
oh,
what's he done to his wife?
But now he's been with that bird for 25
years.
So you can't really get into him as
much.
I start dating and a bird.
No.
You know British justice,
you know Brian,
you know,
silly goose,
a Beatles song.
Blackbird is about Rosa parks.
Wow.
Because Paul Mccartney was going good
with that black bird,
did they?
It was pretty cool.
Wow.
So for birds,
like a person or a girl?
I go just to go and a girl?
Yeah.
Like normally if you say this is my bird
or those birds look nice.
You wouldn't normally about an
attractive woman.
Big called a bird?
Yeah.
Would you ever fuck a real bird?
It's like an eagle.
I feel bad about it.
I'll answer the question.
I was going to fuck a Birdie.
Have you had to flick burden?
It would be.
It would be something with long legs.
I didn't have to squat or anything like
that.
The peacock or then you could just hold
the burden.
Fuck it.
But I'm thinking like an amiable or an
ostrich or Flamingo Flamingo pink.
And then I'd be pretty comfortable with
that.
Flamingo
mango smell like shit.
When you walk past the Flamingo thing,
you would totally lose your bone or they
can balance on one leg,
neck to choke,
but they live in the,
uh,
at the La Zoo.
It's like a shit pool.
Just a pool of bird shit on generally
have a zoo in San Diego and La didn't
really the difference between a bird
burden.
A mammals.
I would feel bad if I fucked a mammal,
like if I fucked a dog and be like,
oh,
sorry dude,
I'd feel bad because I like animals.
But a dog's got a memo,
isn't sure.
Of course.
I thought we were mammals.
Mammals,
a warm blooded furry creature.
I get mixed up.
All right.
So while I was on fish right there
actually,
but I still like,
I don't give a shit.
It's a fish.
Whales are actually mammals.
Haley blow.
Whoa,
whoa.
They'd be there too.
But you also have a bottle.
Funny that nothing that breeze water is
smart and that kind of cool water.
Stupid.
Except for like octopus geniuses.
They reckon.
Yeah.
They think they're kind of smart,
which is why when you eat like a baby
octopus salad or something,
that's why people don't want eight
dolphins because they're geniuses,
but now eating new fetus size,
that's pretty dangerous place to go
with.
Well,
it's pretty dangerous to lock up
dolphins and killer whales.
That's even more dangerous because
that's something that we know that
talking to each other,
we know they have a complex language.
We don't give a fuck or whatever.
It's such a confined space for the
terrible.
Not only that,
there's a thrill and killing things.
There's look,
people get a charge out of being a
hunter gatherer,
like people that go hunting.
When you go fishing and catch a fish,
there's like a primal like release that
you get from that and that's like it's.
It's natural.
It's like a part of like the reward
system.
The nature's put in place to make sure
you carry on,
so they have all these raging,
raging hormones inside of them and all
these killer instincts to take things
out.
They're supposed to be killing shit left
and right.
This is fucking killer.
Whales that these gigantic monster is
animals and they don't know shit.
Dolphins on into killing.
Just little fish dolphins killed
themselves.
They.
They killed little dolphins.
They kill baby dolphins.
The dolphins murder each other.
It's fun to grab onto the thin though.
I like the touch,
romanticize it,
but the,
the world underwater.
It's cool as fuck.
You know,
killer whales eat dolphins and dolphins
regularly.
Babies to kill baby dolphins thing,
but know that they would help baby
humans,
which is funny.
They.
So what a killer whale.
He just murdered babies all the time and
the only,
the only wells that have been
documented,
there's been rumors about people now.
The only way as Wales that have been
documented as killing people,
the ones that are in captivity,
they actually help people never killing
the wild.
Yeah,
but that's the same thing.
Sting,
right?
How many sting rays at paypal before
fucking Steve Owen came involved.
Some.
I'm sure it's like four or five direct
write something real low number.
You just can't fuck with something like
that.
But the thing is,
that's why they go,
oh,
we'll never released the footage out of
respect because they know he wasn't
patting it going,
isn't this a lovely thing?
Look at this.
You know,
he was grabbing the title guy,
we're gonna kill Ya.
And he pointing it up to God.
Could you imagine if you did,
if that's really what was going on,
do you think that they would own the
American public or the public?
The worldwide public rather,
they would owe them that just for.
Just to.
To know that,
to say don't ever do this,
don't do this.
These little.
It was,
it wasn't even his show.
It was for his daughters show for like
the Disney channel or whatever.
And his daughter was on the boat and
then just go.
I reckon he would have lived it.
I didn't pull it out.
It would have flunked everything in it.
They left it in.
They would have lived in town,
but he pulled it out.
Oh Jesus.
Fucking Christ.
I went swimming with,
with sting rays about a month later,
like hundreds and hundreds of them.
Dan In antigo let fucking idiots like me
in the water,
so they're obviously pretty plastic
dental.
I don't know if they're all the same
species.
I think there's a bunch of different
kinds of sting rays to.
I don't think know what he was fucking
with.
Yeah,
well the thing is some of them are only
like very few of them are poisonous
stingers,
but he didn't.
It wasn't that.
It was pointed as it went through his
hot,
you know,
everybody it was.
He's a weird,
weird guy because like everybody really
loved that guy.
Apparently.
It was a super nice guy.
Everybody loved him.
He put all these money back into
conservation and stuff.
Like he was very charitable man so.
But there were people that looked at
some of the shit he did and we're
laureus like when he was holding his
child while feeding a crocodile,
that was good.
That was the most ridiculous shit I
think I've ever seen a person and they
had a little baby running away.
I kind liked that though.
I didn't like that at all.
That's ridiculously cocky.
Just because that thing is never jacked
you before,
doesn't mean it can't right now.
If it's just decides it needs more than
that chicken.
Are you really confident in what it's
fucking die been for the last couple of
weeks?
The baby is the size of a big chicken.
They would be happy to eat you.
There was a bunch of kayakers that we're
going through some fucking river and uh,
one of them got taken out by a
crocodile.
So real recent things and like was it a
New York Times article or something like
that.
But from the perspective of the other
two guys that were kayaking in a fucking
crocodile came and checked them.
You imagine you're in the position that
you would,
what,
what it would feel like to be on a kayak
and just get taken out by a giant
dinosaur.
Just something that was alive $100
million years ago.
It looked exactly the same because I
reckon the big difference between
crocodiles and alligators,
crocodiles search for food and
alligators sit and white really know
now.
I gotta do is sit in a swamp in Miami
and just until,
until something stupidly looked like a
rock until something extreme is by where
a crocodile just wakes up in the
morning,
Guy,
I'm going to fucking catch something so
you can't fuck with them as much.
White label line,
they're very aggressive.
There was a park in Florida where they
raise crocodiles and alligators together
and when they're designing,
the crocodiles left when you can,
when the crop,
when they were feeding them,
the crocodiles running over the heads of
the alligators to get the food.
It was,
it was ridiculous.
You just looked at it,
you went,
whatever that thing is,
fuck that thing.
The alligator is uh,
the fags of the crocodile.
Clearly.
Yeah.
I lived in Florida.
I was around alligators all the time
when I was a kid.
I lived there for a couple of years,
is as long as it,
it bothered me,
Lake Alice,
but they would snatch dogs every now and
then.
Some of them would fuck up and walk
their dog too close to the shore and
they would snatch it.
And it's scary shit.
When you hear about some little old lady
and her fucking dog gets
yanked away from her man,
imagined what that is for her,
her little buddy,
you know she's walking in the hills.
You probably get it around here as well
with people are telling us not to have a
dog because fucking mountain lions will
come and eat your dog just in the
Hollywood hills.
It can happen.
It's rare.
You know,
I'm more likely if you have a small
dogs,
coyotes.
Coyotes are dangerous.
They'll snatch dogs for people too.
They've done that many times.
They're there.
They're tricky Fox and they also will
gang up on people or on a.
well,
they haven't people.
A girl died last year in Toronto or
outside of Toronto.
Some artist.
She was A.
I think it's trying to some somewhere in
Canada,
so I thought it was Toronto might not
have been,
but it was somewhere in the woods.
She's going for a nature walk.
She was 19 years old,
is singer.
Apparently.
She's like a really good singer and a
music contract.
She got jacked by a bunch of.
Was she good looking guy?
Killed by dogs,
basically big,
wild,
crazy dogs.
My girlfriend is gave me a look when I
might check.
She didn't like that Jay.
Wow.
Because the implication was the ugly
people should be allowed to die.
That's not pleasant.
No,
that's not.
I'm not saying they should die.
I'm just saying that if you're going to
save one out of the to save the pretty
one.
Yeah,
of course.
Of course.
You have to do that before you get on
planes.
Before I got on a plane,
I sit there and I try to work out who I
want to live and who I want to die.
When it crashes.
Right.
Like I said,
they're going,
whose company?
When one was comfortable with in this
group.
As always,
the pretty ones they leave.
Sometimes it's just the person with a
warm sort of look to them.
You know?
I always think of myself,
I wanted to just decide like some grand
just like Hitler.
I just sit there.
They're going live,
live,
dead,
alive.
I go wipe out whole families because I
wasn't even mourning or crying.
Right?
So if one of your family goes,
your fucking go,
that means every time you want one of
the hot daughters,
you have to get the whole family then
right now then.
Yeah,
I suppose,
yeah,
keep on going on because she'll need
comforting.
I'm always pitching me.
It's always going to be like on a snow
crest inhale or something.
But I only really fly domestically
across America.
It's not going to be that bad.
Did you see that Liam Neeson movie where
they're the.
I've heard it's great.
I haven't seen it,
but I had to chase him down the gray.
Yeah,
snow bad man.
It's unrealistic because the wolves
don't really behave like that.
But uh,
it's uh,
it's pretty interesting when you,
you hear about people that actually have
been killed by wolves.
It's a lot more than I thought it was
ready.
Made some chicken killed last year in
Alaska by wolves and I thought,
wow,
that's probably really rare.
I bet that's only happened like once in
100 years.
No,
no,
it happened a lot.
It used to happen a lot.
People used to get killed by wolves.
It was like a total normal part of life.
There's all these documented cases of
people killed by wolves.
That's why Peter and the wolf was such
an entertaining program back then.
Yeah.
The,
the big bad wolf.
What is the big bad?
Well,
why is that?
The know goes to grandma's house and
there's a big bad wolf waiting because
wolves were fucking real band.
Like if people lived,
especially in parts of Europe,
especially in Russia,
like they got wolf problems.
Man Moves are scary.
They scared the shit out of any animal.
Really.
Any animal for sure,
but wolves,
I get scared of bugs,
man sometimes are just disgusting.
We talked about this yesterday.
Had scabies once.
That's gross.
That'll.
That'll do your heading scabies.
Oh my God.
I read about a dude from 1920 or
wherever the fuck it was.
He was up in Canada trapping and he
killed for wolves by shooting them and
then like eight more by clubbing them to
death with his rifle before rifle,
but broke and then they killed him.
Wow.
Scary.
I'd be terrified.
I've still never seen a bear in the
wild.
I have.
I'd like to see you.
It's embarrassing.
So it's interesting.
Weird.
It's a weird for anybody to sell that as
a ring tone for color.
You just made $50,000,000.
Not that much.
I Bet I make 20 bucks dot.
Yeah.
We'll scare the shit out of me.
That's real.
What was it?
How is that possible that I.
I create a whatever time I was ever.
Rules are scary.
It's the DUBSTEP remix,
whatever.
Apple.
Just scary.
That's.
That's awesome.
Powerful.
Jim.
Jefferies.
Powerful.
That's where he text me this new thing.
It's been around for years or is this
the one American site?
I've been saying it for years and a bird
crusher says it and Duncan trussell
says,
it already says that there's a poster
over there that says we know what it
all.
My friend laughed pretty strong against
it from my friend Larry.
Larry used to Sadie.
It was his,
he would say powerful and he would do a
head slap.
Powerful.
Yeah.
Was.
Was that Larry from the three?
No,
no,
no.
Like all this.
Too much information is coming in.
I auditioned the three stages.
Maybe you real fuck.
Why the stupidest the guy went in before
me was the guy who got it like a but to
play mo and everyone else was in the
waiting room in outfits,
like really putting effort in and I
hadn't put a lot of effort in and I.
It was like you had to do what I
slapping,
right?
Probably saying yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
All by yourself.
Oh No,
there's no one there to slap.
And it was one of those things where
we're like,
you know,
like they,
they never tell you that you've done
badly,
but they also.
Did I tell you,
your agent,
they go,
oh,
he was okay,
but we're going a different way because
they don't want to have that
conversation with the needy agent either
and so.
But they told my agent I was woeful,
that I was really,
really bad.
You will blow fly.
No,
I won't ever use the word willful.
but I might have been phrasing there,
but I was.
I was pretty bad.
If you don't have anyone to slap though
it does it look like you're just shooing
butterflies or something a little bit of
like.
Well you act like you're slapping it.
Yeah.
Hey.
And then like during the poking things
without doing the pool.
No one with me and just watched like two
students films that afternoon just to
get me in the mood.
I was only meant to watch one but I kind
of enjoyed it so I watched another one
you don't use.
They don't to come on in the audition
wearing a complete green suit when it's
green screen suits and the little balls
all over.
You expect you to do that kind of
improvisation or no person there with
the guy who got it was the same guy who
played Robin Williams in a bio TV show
about him,
like a NBC midday movie.
Good impression.
He must be a good impression,
but he had.
He had the wig and everything and he was
wrong in the waiting room.
He was already for it.
Where does it bring it?
Back to three stooges,
man.
That's officially out of ideas and they
bring my Abbott and Costello who
snookie's in the previous Abbott Abbott
and Costello Man.
Really?
How could you do that?
Those were two actual people.
I'm going to start with the three
stooges,
except they kept on replacing Mo with
the other one,
sham or sharp or whatever,
but I always felt like they were
characters and shuffle with us.
I always felt like,
like name,
you might as well bring wasn't shamp.
That guy's name really wasn't curly.
Yeah.
You're never going to bring back Lewis
and Martin.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
Yeah.
It seems like,
uh,
the characters you could bring back the
character curly and have another guy
play it,
maybe get away with it.
There was,
there was another students pick wasn't
there where they had the guy from the
shield playing.
Oh God.
Oh.
Michael Chiklis hired it.
And it was,
uh,
it was,
it was a mini series of three day mini
series and it was produced by Mel Gibson
because he's a big stooges guy.
That was a great show.
The Shield.
Whew.
That was one of my favorite cop shows,
man.
Oh yeah.
That was.
It was probably the most realistic cop
show ever.
I saw this.
How realistic was I saw the.
Remember the guy that had like the real
sort of weird bye guys.
It was when he killed his wife and the
kid at the end,
I'll use the main characters especially
to kept fucking up and fuck it up,
but he's a bit of a psychopath.
Would just kill people.
Yeah.
I saw him at whole foods like four days
ago and I got a little bit little chill
like I'm at home.
I've actually had that.
Oh,
I wonder what he's going to kill
someone.
I don't suck.
Well,
he was a perfect guy for that role.
To me.
He looked like that guy,
like dangerous,
thick looking crazy fuck cops shoot you
and make up a story about it and pass a
lie detector test.
I was.
It was good.
That was a good fucking show.
It really is weird that seeing people
that you see on TV is in real
life though.
Like I saw that the guy from last the
other day,
day at the dinged,
gone show.
The guy that was also in Lord of the
Rings,
the Irish Guy,
Irish guy.
I'm just sitting there going,
he died at comedy.
Silly Bitch.
Yeah,
because they all died and you watched
the last episode.
I wrote the hose.
I'm his.
I loved his story arc though.
That was a cool story.
Like you know,
him being in that band can hooked on.
Smack was.
It was fear.
That was a good storyline.
Which he started banging that bird.
Who was the lead out of it.
That was pretty good for him.
So he was a real life because he was a
hobbit before that and that's a big
leap.
Leap.
Lily.
That girl is fucking pretty.
I was a cake guy.
I liked the cake girl.
Oh,
it's fucking pretty too.
And she got her teeth fixed.
I don't know.
She had a little gap gap.
Gap Gap.
Yeah.
Worry about that guy.
Trying to think of hot.
Getting hot gap women throughout hot
man.
I like it.
A little gap.
Lego.
Yeah.
Who some hot gap,
but donor in a day.
Was it a hot women?
I find Bella,
Donna hot chicks with flaws of the best
hot but with like one little nagging
webbed feet,
nagging thing.
You don't want to just be like missing a
tick.
You want it to be feared webbed feet.
Would you separate that shit or would
you just go aquaman type pity?
I would show it to people.
It was just like one web show,
like a big toe to the next one.
Just on one foot.
I would rock it out.
Well,
what is the webbed feet about?
I don't know,
but what's the president actually
developed that Rick,
Jesus Christ fader webbed in the womb
and the last thing that happens,
the buddy in the toe separate in
separate.
And I think it's just the last little
bit didn't,
didn't happen.
That's interesting.
What's the percentage of the small toe
being retarded?
Because I haven't,
you know,
my brother,
my pinkies are pretty much retarded.
Like there's something wrong with it or
my little toe,
you know,
everyone's a little crooked and it looks
like a pig tail.
And then like the toe nail doesn't
really grow.
Tell you,
let me see.
But you know,
you told me that you slept in those.
So I'm gonna say no,
I'll have a look at it.
Can you can target me.
Oh,
I always find it weird when you see the
girls who get it because I keep my
toenails clipped.
I imagine I do a fair job,
but nothing remarkable and goal.
It's clipped denial so much that she
just does that like little toenail.
It's not like it's just slid up the and
made us what?
And then the ghost steel ball is to
paint it that little bit.
Just over the top.
It's like when you see that girl put red
lipstick on and she smears it a little
or something.
That is kind of weird.
That little phantom last toenail.
So you don't have the nail,
you just have to slither.
I have this sliver sometimes it doesn't
even grow.
Everything is just taking it off and
just
being done with it.
Yeah.
Use of it.
Comes up with these nails,
man.
That's the weird thing.
Things that grow a useless,
right?
Yeah,
they're useful.
The good for clogging,
but they're so weak you just don't know
how to use them yet,
but your toenails useless fuckers and
they was stronger than the hand.
What do you think that caveman had like
much stronger fingernails from.
If you were Jack and things with your
nails all the time.
Would they get thicker wood?
They grow long.
They get real sick in the back of it and
look at a Guinness Book of records stuff
that kind of them.
Because if once I said as long as joins
that blood flow and she did not curling
and stuff.
Hold Up,
son joins your bloodflow yeah.
When they.
When I'm talking,
when they get like,
yeah.
Then they get there and I start curling
and Qa.
Yeah.
I reckon these people have to have
special surgery because I kind of just
caught them at the base.
Oh my God.
That's become an extension of you more
than just fucking Christ.
You're a tree God damn nail tree.
That's supposed to turn into your
trends.
Like what would,
if that was supposed to do that for a
reason,
like you were supposed to grow up with
that big and it's turned into like a
time machine.
That's always the theory of evolution.
It's like whenever something new is on
the human body,
we cut it out.
We go and we don't know what this is.
We're cutting it out.
What if these persons is the most
evolved person?
I don't know,
like an Ipod is growing out of their arm
or something.
What if you cut his nails off and then
he has like the phantom nail itch.
We feel some touching things.
They're not there anymore.
It feels like,
you know,
amputated his hand.
That guy had like nerve damage because
the guy in the Guinness Book.
Yeah,
there's a whole lot of them that are
into it.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
You got to Indie Shit like that.
Just in these weird man.
You just see it is weird and he's just a
weird place.
There's a lot of people,
right?
So anytime you get a lot of people,
you've got a billion people think I have
any weird people in America with 330
million.
Go it.
India got a billion.
It's a lot more weirdness that can.
That can carry on.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
It's like that's what I always thinking
that America gets a bad rep because
Australians and British are always going
on about how idiotic Americans
Americans.
It's just that you get to publicize yos
more Americans aren't any more stupid
than the British or Australian.
Yeah,
well they're stupid people all over.
Oh,
over the world.
But you have more of them because you
just per capita,
you'd have more of them.
It might be that,
but it also might be,
this is a this.
This is a country that's lived in
prosperity for so long.
There's a lot of soft minded folks who
haven't had.
They haven't had the question the way
things are really running.
They haven't had to investigate things.
They sort of sat back and let let
everything sort of happened.
It wasn't until recently.
I think that people are finally starting
to realize that you really can't do
that.
You can't just trust the government
because they can't be trusted that they
run a muck.
There's a lot of people though that
haven't done that yet.
Nah,
they recognize me.
Forty percent of all Americans have
passports,
so that's the one that I always find
upsetting.
It's incredible.
It would be at least 90 percent of my
passports because it's isolated country,
but there's a bit of you that goes,
well,
maybe that's because in America you can
go to Disneyland.
It's already there.
You know,
like we're all coming on holidays over
over to see your shit.
You've already got all your shit and
it's very nice.
Yeah,
I know.
This is a strange country,
ma'am.
They're all strange.
George Bush sport and still he was
president.
That's amazing,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Any president.
What was he doing before?
Yeah,
if I can pass for any and he goes,
powerful man in the world and never
traveled.
Just traveled under different names.
He's a fascinating dude.
I would love to drink with George Bush
and just find out what the fuck he
really thinks about things.
Can you imagine?
I have a friend who,
and I can't say his name because he's a
fairly famous actor.
Well,
I have a friend who shagged one of these
girls.
Dude,
you just open up a can and shit.
He just opened up a can of shit.
They're going to find you and they're
gonna waterboard your ass until you give
up that dude.
We're already dead for real,
man.
You can't just come on our show and do
that.
Like I know that people are fucked dude.
That's not what I heard.
I just want to know if these ticklers,
if he's George W is,
what do you think actually happened to
him when he had that black guy and he
said he ate a pretzel and choked and
blacked out and fell down.
I believe.
Exactly.
That's what happened.
I can see him eating a pretzel and
frequently.
I think that's what happened as well
because you'd make up unless idiotic
life.
His Dad,
his dad put up a fucking leather glove
on it,
slapped him,
beat his ass while he was eating a
pretzel.
Maybe you start talking some shit like,
well,
who's the president now is Emilio used
to be.
You're right.
Yeah,
but it's me now.
Right?
Cool.
I just want to know.
You did one term right now.
I'm on my second fucker.
Just put on leather glove tickled and
Herbert Walker.
George senior was the head of the CIA.
The dude was no joke.
He'd probably interrogated them.
So you got to say fell off both of them.
Would you like.
Did you like the good guys in your mind?
Well,
not based on anything they ever did with
the world.
I don't know them personally.
I think drugs would be a cool guy to
hang out with.
Just seems like a bit of a laugh.
I bet he.
I bet if you could really pick that
guy's brain if you know,
if you were given access to this memory
banks,
I bet it would be quite fascinating
because I bet that's a guy who's just a
puppet just to fucking happy guy.
Who was a,
you know,
a guy who was part of a big,
influential family and I think they just
told him what to say and he went out and
said it looks like.
What's he doing now?
You some time Clintons always doing
stuff.
George hasn't done nothing since he's
left.
He's probably watching this on this
change.
Just got a new heart,
you know,
they just gave him a new heart.
The Tin Man.
Yeah man,
they got a heart transplant.
Apparently before that he had a machine
hooked up like some sort of a pump in
his body.
So no,
no.
It's more complicated.
Whatever it did,
it didn't.
He didn't have a pulse anymore.
This thing sort of helped him pump the
blood and like if you try to do as
pulse,
who would have no pulse but he was
alive.
Why?
Yeah.
But why wouldn't you still have a
potent?
No,
apparently not because it wasn't pumping
into pulsing way.
He was just pumping in a stream.
It was like,
well,
you know what I'm saying by that it
wasn't going.
It was just flowing.
Exactly.
I think that's the.
That's what I would guess,
but being an idiot and know nothing
about medical science,
I like to think of.
It's one of the things that I use that a
fireplace.
They put a bellows fellow,
but that was one of those things that
you saw from petrol with gasoline.
Yeah.
I guess that the pump though is the
actual heart muscle working.
You know the pump is the actual heart
muscle pushing it out.
It's the heart muscle is not working and
this pump is doing so.
Is it an artificial heart?
Is that what it is?
Whatever the fuck it was.
He didn't have a pulse because of this
thing and then they opened them up.
Hurts are weird.
Fuck,
I don't know how to become synonymous
with luxury is fucking things.
Well,
there's a reason for it and the reason
they recently discovered,
and this is just I think within the last
couple of years that there's at least as
many neurons in the heart as there are
in the brain theory about where someone
gets a heart transplant.
I've heard these stories where someone
gets a heart transplant and then all of
a sudden I can speak French.
No,
that we give too much credit to the
brain and other organs can do shit.
Well that's you know.
I don't know if that's real or not.
I don't know if anybody's ever come to
an organ transplant and given a
depiction of the person's life,
but if you were going to do it from any
organ transplant,
I would say the heart,
a bad candidate because of all the
neurons in see,
they don't know where the fuck your
memory comes from.
Memories a mystery because every cell in
your body is replaced every seven years.
Your cells all get replaced like there's
a new device,
but it's stored or you're saying,
here's the issue.
It go those cells,
those brain cells to regenerate.
They all,
all of them.
Every one doesn't though is neurons.
Neurons apparently you keep for life
kind of brain hurts.
Like if you heard part of the brain,
they know where memory is stored based
on people getting injuries to specific
locations of the brain.
Like how their brain,
you know how they,
you know,
like they know like the,
like fun frontal lobe academies.
They figured that out.
They knew where they could do them to
Zombie you out.
They found the right spot where the
dude,
by the way,
one of the fucking Nobel prize,
the guy who made lobotomies won a Nobel
prize.
They thought he was awesome.
I do way to go hit Louis.
Tom's man and you silence these retards.
You fucking drill a hole in their head
and scoop out their brains.
I was like,
shock therapy.
It's pretty crazy.
Do you ever say that?
I had a close relative go through that
when?
When they were younger.
Really?
Yeah,
the right down on the drive down the
rabbit stake and if I can see we're
going to fucking mic.
Like this whole idea that we're going to
kill the psycho out of you with
electric.
Like oh,
that's.
That was happening right up until the
eighties in Australia.
Shock therapy.
And that's,
that's like so close to when they like
bleeding and using leeches in medicine.
Like to go,
Oh yeah,
we'll just electrocute people.
Well it's electricity seemed so cool and
so powerful.
It's like,
well let's just hook them up to that
shit.
See if it fixes it.
This kind of schizophrenia.
This'll help.
Could you imagine what that must fucking
feel like.
I'm fighting it because you're already a
bit mental and then the nurse is holding
you down.
When you think about doing this,
how did it start off?
Did they do it on mice first and then
we're like,
wow,
that mouse is crazy.
And then they shocked.
It was like,
oh,
it's not,
it's not moving around.
She blinded me with.
That's funny.
Yeah.
How did they figure that out?
Some crazy ass hole started on humans.
It just doesn't seem right.
The same Nobel prize winning asshole.
Scrambling people's.
We look back like cause bleeding.
It's got to be the most stupid of them.
All right.
When you're really sick.
Yeah.
They cut all your blood out and dripped
it into balls because they thought
they're getting when you needed more
than ever.
Yeah.
Are we going to in 50 years go.
They used to give these kids that
couldn't breathe these little puffers
that made it worse and gave them,
you know,
they're going to be things from now that
we're going to look back at and go,
that was fucking man.
It's well chemotherapy saying like,
man,
you know,
it'll seem like madness,
prescription drug abuse.
When they find out how many different
people are hooked on all sorts of
different pain killers.
Some real American thing.
I.
I'd never been in Britain.
It's where I'm taking most of my drugs.
No,
I never met anyone that wanted to.
I never knew what an Oxycontin was there
until a couple of years ago.
Government is better at filtering the
stuff and doesn't have socialized
medicine.
Yeah.
That's the difference right there.
It's probably not as easy to get.
See in America,
it's real easy to get that stuff.
All you have to do is be injured
pharmaceutical drugs or you know,
really.
You know,
they've helped a lot of people,
a lot of people have benefited for sure
from,
from discoveries that have been in.
He kept people alive.
That would have been dead.
A lot of really cool things have been
discovered,
but there's also a,
a lot of money and pharmaceutical drugs.
Sure.
Whenever there's a lot of money in
something and that's something just
happens to be addictive and then the
money starts pouring in.
Well they get addicted to that money.
You can't tell a pharmaceutical company
that loses,
you know,
eight,
10,000
people a year to whatever the fuck
they're selling.
You can't tell them that you're,
you can't,
you can't sell that stuff anymore.
You got to stop.
Everyone in America has this little
thing like we obviously without jobs fly
a lot and whenever I get on a plane,
like I speak to my management or agents
or something,
I go,
fuck it.
I want to just fly to kind of sleep on
pines.
Those just take a Xanax easy,
just take a xanax and they say it so
bland sight.
You're like,
no,
it's.
And then you think these are what these
people are doing.
Just when they were home in bed,
tossing and turning a little bit.
Sometimes it's just fucking hard to go
to sleep.
Right next week is that I will dump my
railroad went off about Xanax.
He's been taking it for four or five
years.
Talking about it.
I don't think so.
It didn't sound like he liked it sounded
like you needed.
It sounded like he enjoyed it.
He likes it.
Yeah,
I know what I mean.
Yeah.
No,
I get complete what you're saying.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people on that stuff
though.
It's a real common strain.
Child Heath Ledger and all.
Then we can hit legend.
Never was a recreational drug taker at
all really.
But he just got really into like our
numerous loop and didn't sleep well.
There's a long fucking days.
There's a lot of people.
Yeah,
those,
those movie star dudes.
So it seems like an easy life.
But when you're on a site,
you might have to work 16 hours a day
and you have to put out all that energy.
A lot of them get sick,
a lot of them need B,
12 shots.
It's not an easy man,
especially when you're acting at that
level.
You know,
like I was a bad motherfucker.
He was a good actor.
Made out with a dude.
Yeah,
they went out of strong.
I've seen seen the last three short yet
that I see what?
Life's too short.
The new a ricky device TV show.
No,
just a sharp that dwarfs.
It's funny to sit calm about Dorson HPI,
but if you haven't seen no references,
basically they make a whole lot of
dwarfs go through a famous scenes in
movie history and there's a brokeback
mountain.
It was just funny to watch it to English
doors going.
I'm definitely gay.
Oh my word.
I'm enjoying this,
but if you haven't seen it,
I'm not going to talk about.
I haven't seen it.
It's great.
It's very good.
What was that video you were showing me
earlier from the bone zone of students
kissing each other.
How do people find that?
Oh yeah.
If you go on Youtube,
it's randy littky and Davey Johnson and
the video is called an intimate moment
on the bone zone and that's just from
one of the podcasts we do at desk squad.
Brendan Walsh,
who was,
um,
I think he's in.
Where's he at?
Somewhere in Seattle or something
somewhere because he asked me to tweet
it.
Uh,
but he's got a podcast on the desk squad
and it's called the bone zone.
That's,
he's a fucking funny dude.
So anything he's doing so kissing,
kissing in every episode.
And so we.
It's really funny though.
They're really funny guys.
Seattle?
Yeah.
He's so Seattle folks.
He's a in Vancouver tonight and tomorrow
too.
So look on Brendan Walsh Dot Com.
Oh,
there you go.
Brendan and I gave you a plug.
Fuck,
check this out.
I asked Don as Don Burris has been
locked out of his own facebook account
for four days a hacker,
but we were just saying some nice things
about Brendan Walsh.
I have to go negative.
I just trying to see Brendan Walsh.
No,
but Brendan Walsh.
It's Hilarious,
isn't he?
Yeah.
Brian,
shouldn't people go see him?
Yeah,
I don't really,
I don't really know him,
but he sounds very funny,
but somebody took his fucking facebook
account and changed all his email and
stuff and now he can't get back into it
and facebook won't help them at all.
So like now there's just somebody
looking out all this shit,
looking at his photos.
I have an ex girlfriend that hates him,
know somebody hacked his shit.
Everyone's one of those.
Yeah.
But does he have um,
does he have enemies or people you know,
all that shit he does with a scary Perry
and all the,
you know,
that shit like that,
that there might be people that are
against that or something.
Yeah,
if you don't know he,
they did a movie.
What is the name of the windy city he
did?
Oh,
I love this movie.
I love that film.
And was a part of that.
It's paid it does it cool moments and
then you just have to remember that that
caused a bit of an assault.
He's a weird guy to be around,
that's for sure.
But wow.
They took it deep.
I mean they,
they,
they made a movie about this guy being
famous and he really believed it.
I mean,
to me that's like a part of that is like
you're picking on mental illness is
clearly this guy's.
There's a disconnect between this guy in
reality,
like it's funny Sorta,
but man,
you talking about like the ultimate,
the joke's on you picking on a crazy
person,
but one thing it might be that's
different than that argument is that the
crazy people all want to be comics or
actors so they know what they're doing.
What we've done,
we've done Ip and Anthony together a
fair bit and every time I do it,
one of the RSA re todd's one of the
crazies that are on the show.
Sometimes I go home feeling a little bit
down about it and then I remember that I
love it.
That's their lives.
They've got a level of fame.
They go to these conventions or
whatever.
When I'd be anti do things on the road
and they get big.
Round of applause isn't very exciting,
but it is just picking on a mental.
You'll perse.
I think there's a way to do it in a way
not to do it.
Dawn does it,
right.
Like one of the guys is schizophrenia,
surfer guy.
I used to do open mics with this guy and
he,
he's got schizophrenia and he's really
hardcore schizophrenia.
But he would do like an act and then
like afterwards I would always try to
talk to him but he would like look past
me and,
and it was weird.
But what is schizophrenia entail?
What else was wrong with to
personalities,
right?
I don't know.
He's just really,
it seems like that's not bipolar is not
to personally bought Paul is Paul
depression that's up as being dead.
Schizophrenia is you start believing
you,
someone else going in and out of
different personalities sometimes you
can talk to other times you just looked
past here and plus the fact that he
smokes weed on top of that.
It's kind of like really weird.
But uh,
but he's a real nice guy,
but as an example that I used to do open
open minds with him and now he's fucking
love and doing the Dingdong show.
Okay.
This is,
it is,
um,
it makes it difficult to tell the
difference between real and unreal
experiences.
Think logically,
have normal emotional responses.
Behave normally in social situations.
So.
Huh?
So what's the jewel personality?
One?
A will you can.
There's,
I think there's a will.
There's people that don't believe in
multiple personality disorder.
They think it's horse shit.
There are people that think it's horse
shit.
Hey,
they just want attention.
Yeah.
I don't know anybody that was threatened
friend and he's a good friend of mine,
but I have a friend of mine who uh,
who says that he had a split
personality,
but it was just whenever he acted like
an asshole that was,
oh,
that was such and such just came out and
you're like,
Nah,
he just did not say that.
Your,
you and you're good.
Were you when your bed as well?
Yeah,
that's ridiculous.
Um,
some people have it I guess.
I guess a dissociative identity
disorder.
Their fence rail.
Well it is,
but it's people who actually changed
their name and I'm candy now and I have
a dog.
Yeah.
Well,
you know who did that was I'm the dude,
a Herschel Walker.
Herschel Walker apparently had some
serious problems with visual.
Oh,
he's a famous football player who's an
older guy and he's now competing in mma.
He's like,
he's in his time.
He was like one of the greatest football
players of all time,
ridiculous athlete and now he's 48 years
old,
shredded just and just destroying people
in mixed martial arts fights.
And that was his background is a kid
from Australia.
You got signed up to I think one of the
big NFL teams yesterday.
And uh,
never held an American football.
That's amazing.
You played rugby,
but they just made him dula tackling
stuff and then statistically is off the
chart,
straight into the NFL and never touched
a ball.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
The NFL wants super athletes.
You know,
he's like 26,
eight,
just powerhouse top of Blake's.
Fuck.
There's some people you get around them.
You can't believe that that's a real
person.
That's a person to like,
I'm the same as that person with the
same.
He's given me check.
There's a guy and he's the uncle Jonah
Lomu,
who's fairly well,
uh,
like portrayed in that movie addict this
or whatever.
What about the rugby World Cup?
But that's the biggest kind of that.
What's that movie?
The one with met diamond and a fucking
okay.
Nelson Mandela.
I didn't see them.
It was that good.
That was pretty good,
man.
He did a fucking excellent.
Nelson Mandela.
I've ever get a gig data.
No know.
I'll hook you up with this guy,
man.
He likes big.
Yeah,
it's fucking great man.
There's the people are awesome.
The food is outstanding.
You just kind of walked the streets
right?
It's just one of those things where it's
barbwire fences and shit everywhere.
She's spot on.
How dangerous is it?
They,
you lucky guns up in lockers when you're
going to the casino and you'll see like
everyone pulling their gun out and just,
Oh my God and this,
but you just don't go through the
townships and you don't try not to have
sex with anyone for a couple of weeks.
That's about,
you know what I mean?
Africa is Africa.
There was a story about a guy
who,
uh,
took his girlfriend to Africa and
arrange for her to be kidnapped and they
kidnapped her and killed her crazy
fucking story,
man that he,
he got down there and he convinced
someone to,
uh,
to,
to kidnap her and uh,
you know,
he was gonna get the ransom money from
like her pants or something like that
and they just fucking killed her.
Yeah.
No ransom money for Dave.
He kidnapped.
Well,
one,
one story.
The other story is that he had or
killed,
you know,
he wanted to move on to some new girls,
so he had her killed,
which is even fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Just break up with him.
I know I can be
dude.
Just get deep.
They just get deep into it and they got
to get out.
Get out now.
Yeah.
The other ways for her to die,
but you can see Lions and tigers.
It's pretty exciting.
What a fucked up thing to do.
Man.
Hired somebody to kidnap your check.
I would love that.
That when you said there's news stories
and tap into a semi Thompson,
which news stories where some moms like
tromping along these black men rip
tattoos just opened the door and stole
my car with my child and it and then you
got back cause got to end up in the
swamp and you put them in the seat belt
and this is going to be awesome.
Right?
But like,
but now it makes you suspicious of every
person who ever cries and TV.
You always watched them going yet you're
a killer.
I always go straight through.
Well,
when you find out that they are,
it is the weirdest feeling in the world,
especially if you've been supporting
them.
If you need going,
that poor lady that pull out.
If you feel cheated as the public,
you're like,
how many times have women?
Yeah.
Then busted doing that where they didn't
know that they were guilty and then they
caught them
in America at Capa.
But there is a,
there is a case in the UK which has been
going on for fucking ever.
And what's,
um,
maddie anyway,
very,
very famous clients in the UK where they
were.
This couple went on holiday in Portugal
that I were in a resort type thing.
They left the kid.
Um,
uh,
madeline mccain was named the logo.
And so I left Maryland Mccain in this
room.
They went off and had dinner like 50
meters away.
She was five years old.
Ladies left.
Are they sleeping when they got back?
She was gone right now.
The case has never been opened,
but people are still of the opinion that
maybe they did it.
Maybe they'd been,
no one can prove.
And then like maybe some pedophile did
it.
Maybe some whatever did it.
But it's,
uh,
it,
it's a real big case.
Like the extended last time we talked
back to Britain,
they had pictures of a five years on
computer generated what she'd look like
now.
So to keep,
keep looking for like the parents are
still like putting an assistant creepy
when they do that fake person.
I used to,
I used to do a joke.
I went,
how long are we going to keep this going
for?
Oh,
I got I hope another six years so we can
get that whole picture of when she's 16.
Yeah.
They start making her like have like
phones on.
Should look now.
Most likely with a collar on her neck.
That's pretty fucked up.
Why don't I just put a realistic picture
of just some bones covered with come.
Oh no fun.
It's fun reading on.
It is.
Yeah,
you can never do that in any other job
and be like sat back.
And we were like wow,
I can't believe you did that,
but that's pretty fucking funny.
You know,
you can't,
you,
you would get in trouble if you were in
upper management somewhere,
you know.
And he said that at a board meeting he
suddenly passed the milk and you hold up
this thing.
Shouldn't this was this a fucking real
thing?
Imagine you shouldn't just be a pile of
bones and come and everybody just.
Alright.
Here an advertising guy.
The poster that my father is quite a
successful business type guy.
I don't,
I couldn't tell you quite what he does,
but he was entertaining clients on a,
on a,
on a boat.
Trying to,
yeah,
right.
Very similar.
So he was at a dining clients that are
like the people,
he was trying to get money out of it.
You developed shopping centers and
stuff.
Right.
So he had this boat and this was years
early on in my career and I had like a
CD,
the first CD and my brother just had it
and he goes,
ah,
everyone wasn't really getting along,
so I thought I'd put your cd on and see
if we could pick the mood up or the
group.
And he goes,
you started with a,
with a dance syndrome.
Jake the fucking guys kid had dancing
drive and we're stuck in Sydney harbor
and we couldn't go back and he was
yelling at me like a fuck these deal up.
You have to put my cd on.
No one option to put it on that much of
a story.
It's what we got,
what we got and we got to work with it.
So I guess this is actually kind of
disputed,
this multiple personality disorder.
Some people think it's bullshit,
but a lot of people think it's legit,
you know,
that's the one person doing that.
Maybe they're all typing in.
None of the different personalities.
This is bullshit.
I don't remember.
I think Hershel Walker thought it was
trauma induced from the years of
football,
which is totally crazy.
Now he's fighting,
you know,
it's like,
wow,
look what you're saying that he'd punch
drunk and that's not necessarily punch
drunk.
I mean there's,
I mean,
he,
he talks fine.
He seems to think fine too,
but there are a lot of people believe
that you could get a lot of things wrong
with your brain from repeated trauma and
the kind of trouble they haven't.
Football is like,
man,
these guys are running at each other and
clashing heads and shit and had to
fucking knees.
And that's,
there's some serious impact that these
guys are withstanding and a lot of them
get fucked up because of it.
I'm pretty sure that's what he was
saying was that it was a trauma related,
um,
multiple personality disorder.
That's just la,
that people still go,
oh,
we're not sure.
Oh,
you sure that.
Sure,
that if they're not sure,
they're silly,
but it's the same as Richard.
Okay.
Richard Pryor and Dudley Moore both took
a lot of cocaine in their days and then
they had the same,
this extraordinarily rare nerve
disorder.
It wasn't just Parkinson's.
It was like a ribbed strain of it,
and then people still go,
oh,
we don't quite know how this happened,
and it's like,
I think.
I think I know.
Yeah.
I know another person who did the exact
same thing and it has the exact same
problem.
Yeah,
it's that.
It's super,
super common.
Mad.
Well,
definitely more kept,
kept sacred for years and everyone,
because they thought he was just a
drunk,
but he,
he,
he was then given up acting and thing.
He used to go out of the concert pianist
because he was a really good pianist and
he.
Yeah,
he used to get halfway to get halfway
through a song and then just sort of the
other microphone.
Everyone was drunk again.
He wasn't drunk.
He was just fucking heavily diseased.
Wow.
The last three or four years of his
group,
no one knew.
Wow.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
That's a good show.
Good show.
Was it back in the day?
Would you buy a DVD?
Would probably be awesome if it came out
at best buy if you want to best buy.
And so that's incredible.
DVD Collection.
It depends on what it was.
I would buy it just to see what a time
traveling device it would be.
I brought the greatest American hero and
I got the greatest American hero and
Netflix the other day because I just
liked it so much as a kid and I now I
watched it.
I just liked the theme song.
Is it?
Is it like that?
Because I remember as a kid,
I really loved that.
Yeah.
So the flying is so stupid.
That noise is so stupid that I can't
believe I was ever fooled or ever made
time travel.
You can go back and see what amused you
when you were a little and be baffled.
Well this is the whole theory on why
kids should not should see gentle porn
because gentle.
You know what I mean?
Because I grew up with like finding a
playboy magazine and then just batting
off to it until I found another magazine
that was,
you know,
kids today are going straight to the
Internet.
They're going to be fun.
You guys find their magazines in the
woods?
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
In the bush.
That incredible.
And I always used to think that some
adults hidden it,
but I looked back at it.
Now there's some other kid hit it there
and the board of the simulation program,
that one,
it's almost like he grew there.
You're supposed to find it.
I it to that environment.
I remember mentioning show you young.
I was about seven years old,
seven and I found these pitching when my
mother was the only woman in the house.
I went through one of her magazines,
so we didn't have underwear catalog
sitting around like a Victoria secret
catalog or something like that would
have been good.
But we're a family picture in my mum's
Women's magazine.
It was just a naked.
And these magazine never had a naked
titone it before.
Right.
So I cut this picture.
This picture,
I masturbated to these picture from
about seven till 10,
like one test is one tip.
Right.
And I found out at 10 because I was
watching the news,
it was a picture of a woman having a
mammogram.
Whoa.
Yeah.
But I didn't know as a kid and I used to
think because the other tick was in a
machine being squeezed out.
Oh.
It was like,
I was like,
that must be some sex machine.
It's amazing.
I kept your interest for so long.
I still do the laundry or anything at
the sears catalog for my friends,
my mom's sears catalog.
And I used to keep it and put it in mind
like books and like hide it in a book
and they pull it out and look at it and
masturbate and shit.
I remember being with the laundry in the
catalogs,
the old catalogs.
We used to have catalogs.
I remember there being a youtube video
and then when I went to university and I
was like 22 or something like that.
Um,
they used to keep on sending me the
catalogs because I bought a couple of
videos years ago and I used to keep them
and they were this,
they were just like pictures of scenes
from the movie they were trying.
I never bought anything but the catalogs
once a month.
That was a big day free and I was broke,
you know,
I was fucking happy that I always used
to keep my roommate one catalog behind
so he would get the new months one after
I got my new man.
It's funny that what you would want then
to see naked girls to look at naked
girls,
that people would deny that if you,
they say you're not ready for that.
Yeah,
I mean that's what it's all about.
It's about protecting kids.
But clearly you have these sexual urges
and everyone's just in denial about it.
Nope.
You're only 16.
You can't buy a playboy.
Like you can't even buy a playboy when
you're 16.
You can't even just let me see a little
titty.
I don't even need to see a vagina.
Can I just see a lag?
But they,
they put it in movie movies when you're
16 weeks.
I've got to commend Britain.
I'm on page three of the units,
papers.
There's a topless go.
Yeah,
that's normal.
That's good.
What 16 year olds can't go to the movies
that show tits.
Tits is not talking about poor keys as a
bit of fitness is important as our
wouldn't porky's.
I think back then it was,
well we're going to strike him,
which is 16.
And he had.
Maybe that is all right.
Yeah,
sure.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
but we have our as well,
but mature was six days.
I was 18.
Shane
does a 17 I think is our,
isn't it?
It and NC 17 is for you.
No matter what.
You can't even go with an adult unless
you're 17.
My Dad,
my father is so deprived of being able
to say tits out because my mom is such a
big,
hefty woman in and he just,
he just,
he's still like a horny sort of like my
dad said when we were kids,
if me and my two brothers were sitting
watching the movie labyrinth,
we,
you're watching like a very innocent
puppet related film all at once during
the family.
He'd be in the house.
We don't go,
oh,
look at those tits Wa.
Within seconds my dad would just
casually walk out and sit and watch the
rest of the film with going to go,
what are you,
what are you watching?
Go all the way through the film and then
you go,
oh,
I'm almost at the beginning of that
film.
I missed what happened.
Trolled him.
You,
oh,
that's hilarious.
And you let them sit through the whole
movie so we don't go and fight and then
he'd have to sit through the first 30
minutes again.
Like,
oh,
that's fucking funny.
Just in the high,
because it was icon.
It's got to happen.
You guys should've filmed that.
That would make a hilarious short film
is explain it and now they were the time
code search and he could still do it.
Now.
You should do.
I could see it.
I get it's filmed.
The light of the TV is what's on Ham,
right?
Little time code and the bottom.
Show him.
Ten minutes later,
20 minutes later,
30 minutes later.
Look at us.
What areas could be hilarious if you
explain it to the camera?
He found he found some porn magazines.
I never retained on this,
but he found some porn magazines.
I know my mother fans a porn magazine is
out of my bed and she put them in the
bin because that's like,
I don't know,
you know,
you put them in the bank and then she
didn't say anything to me.
She just let me off Scot free on it.
She didn't like get angry or anything,
so I felt like I got away with my porn
drawer was empty.
Right.
And I worked in a news agency so I used
to collect them from the bins out the
back of the news agencies.
I had piles and piles of them.
I was a paper boy,
right.
So I,
I,
uh,
I was in my dad's work bench and I was
hammering a nail down.
I look under the bench and there's all
my porn magazines,
but they're all dogeared and they're
like lettuce leaf on them and stuff
because what happened was my dad's got
to take,
he's got to take the bend to the end of
the driveway on a Wednesday.
He opened the garbage bin,
solar porn.
He recovered at all.
I took it off to a shade,
very good vegetables.
So I collected it all back off and I
took it back to my drawer just because
you know,
the circle of life,
right.
And uh,
my dad comes home in the living room,
he comes out and goes,
Jim,
you guys were you in my garage?
And I said,
alright,
I got it.
Yay.
You guys,
you know,
have those magazines and I wait neither.
Yeah,
that was about
$13.
I just said neither you anyway.
Oh,
can I have for actual moment where I
start with my dad and I had a debate,
but I was 13 over.
All right.
You can have a hassle,
a pain.
Taos,
a playboy geezer phone smelt morphing is
your phone right?
You can't leave your phone by the thing.
How many times do we have to tell you
that crazy?
Zap,
Zap airplanes crash.
Men can't leave that shit right by the
MP three player.
Were you getting texts?
Would you rather kiss Nancy Reagan on
the lips or the tit?
Um,
how,
how old is she right now?
Oh,
tit,
definitely.
No Lips,
lips,
lips.
I don't want to suck on an old lady.
Kitty,
like a really old,
like I was 89 or something.
I don't know.
But you can either say you kissed her on
the Uber and Lyft.
No,
not tell anybody.
She brushed it to yourself.
I'd get a respectful kiss on the mouth.
Yeah.
Nice.
Well,
you look very nice today.
Nancy or would also.
Sorry,
your husband's date.
I started,
uh,
tweeted the Deepak Chopra today.
I rarely do,
but sometimes that dude's shit.
That's so ridiculous.
I want to tweet back to him.
He goes,
when you reach pure awareness,
you will have no problems.
Therefore,
there will be no need for solutions and
I wrote back,
if you reach pure awareness and someone
kicks you in the balls,
you still have problems.
That is true and that's a fact.
You can put shit like that on twitter.
Someone's gonna want to you Bob Tupa,
Deepak show pro bro.
How dare you?
Lots of free time.
Do some Indian dude,
some girl.
Take care.
See,
that's exactly exactly what you say.
So you can reach pure awareness,
but your wife still has cancer.
Say you know what I mean?
But you can be completely aware of it,
but that doesn't mean the problem's
gone.
Well,
he's saying you have no problems.
Yeah,
I say he's full of Shit.
Pure awareness.
You will have no problems.
That shit's ridiculous.
You can't just do what you want to do.
You have to take care of things that are
going you fucking roof as a whole and I
guess what?
I bet you got a problem.
I don't give a fuck what you're telling
me.
That's a problem.
You got to get that shit fixed.
Not being aware of.
It's actually makes the problem worse.
She's doing nothing.
Well,
I will meditate under the dripping
water.
Fuck you go get that shit fixed.
You ruin your house,
dummy.
You got a problem facing deep rock.
You're talking nonsense.
God dammit.
That's the problem I have with all these
dudes to talk a lot of hippie nonsense
that they say a lot of shit that they
think that women who just hit menopause
want to hear when they really start
getting into yoga and just try to find
the light and try to find happiness and
get into flowers raising flowers.
That's when he comes in and kind of like
that can just swoop in on that.
I want to be happy market and just start
ping pong and it back and forth with all
these nonsense sentences.
When you reach pure awareness,
you'll have no problems.
Bitch,
stop with that and follow that guy.
No,
I will not want to.
I want to hear more craziness
is a really funny moment on youtube
where he got,
uh,
some,
some guy who's writing a physics book
with Stephen Hawkings,
like it was correcting things.
He was saying the guy was like,
like,
you're,
you're saying like you're saying things
that don't make sense to me.
Correcting Stephen Hawkings?
No,
no,
no.
The Guy who was writing a book with
Deepak Chopra was trying to explain
something to him like quantum distant
quantum that,
and so the guy goes,
yeah,
I know what all those words mean,
but I'm not quite sure what you're
saying because he's not really saying
anything.
He just fucking minded,
didn't it?
The infinite.
The impossible.
The consciousness of the quantum
consciousness.
He just,
he could just say things like that and
you just leave it up to what was gassing
up some sort of a broad sense.
He might've made a sentence there.
There might be some point that he has
that I can't quite grasp,
but much more likely.
It's word salad that's designed to sound
spiritual with salad.
So what it is,
he threw a bunch of cool words together
and this guy called them on it.
This guy was like,
it was so brilliant the way the guy
said,
yeah,
I know what all those words mean.
I'm not making that up the way that guy
talks.
You guys don't know who he is,
who he is.
Do you know he was killed by a Tupac or
Biggie?
Biggie.
Biggie killed the biggie.
Canada.
Why did I go to work?
Better insight to really shouldn't night
anyway.
Both of them.
Supposedly.
That's fine.
It's going to happen in two hours.
The Canyon Club in a Gore Hill hills,
so come on down,
starts in two hours.
It's a great place to go to the barbecue
place first.
What time does your show there?
Seven.
I think it's like,
is it an 8:00
start?
Is it all right?
Well,
let's show starts when you get this on.
Yeah,
that's one of my favorite comics and UK
can.
I didn't call and Tom Stage checking him
out.
Really,
really fucking funny guy.
He's opening for you.
No,
no,
no.
He's just a guy.
He still lives in Britain,
but he said was when I in when I was a
young comic and I was in a car with him.
We're going to a gig and I said,
fuck,
we're going to make for the Gig.
And he went,
we are the Gig.
So that's Dr.
Yeah,
that's what it's up.
Yeah.
We,
I've been many times where we were
really close to being late for shows.
Ari in particular would get very
nervous.
Donkin donkey would have to open.
Fuck man,
I kinda just just drop me off in front.
Don't even park.
I'm like eight.
Oh five were good shows.
Five minutes.
Like who gives a fuck if they,
if they're really mad,
like with your audience.
Gonna be mad.
What kind of asshole would be upset or
to show starting five minutes late.
I'd tell you what.
I went and sold.
So Billy Joel
in concert,
which is how all good stories start.
I mean,
so billy billy Joel in concert in
Sheffield in the north of England and I
was in the third row.
I got the tickets rather light,
but I don't think he's popular in
Sheffield.
Anyway.
So,
so this woman looks at her watch and she
sit next to her husband and she's just
got the shit right.
It's like 10 past eight shows meant to
start at eight.
And she went,
this is fucking bullshit.
Right?
And the husband's gone,
hey,
don't worry,
it'll be fine.
And she said,
no,
we got here on time it he should get
here on time as well.
And we thought,
well maybe they're missing a frame,
right?
She goes over and speaks to security.
Goggin.
Wednesday's going to start with 10,
five slash 10 minutes late.
The security guys just like fuck off
because he doesn't care.
You know what I mean?
And then billy Joel comes out 15 minutes
late probably,
right?
Which is normal time and billy Joel
comes out and then the whole audience
stands up and she just sits there and
yells out.
I paid for a seat and then that husband
was just dragged away and I still think
to this day that's the biggest can't
I've ever seen.
And I've only seen about five sentences
for that.
I felt like grabbing that guy can just
get out of this leave,
Ryan,
you don't need this woman anymore.
She's horrible.
That's the worst you've ever seen.
Really.
It was that bad.
It just,
just in just a short amount of time
where I thought,
this person's just evil,
horrible.
Some people don't ever realize how tall
building,
but I would think that after shows,
you see a lot of those,
right?
Yeah.
You do photos after gigs to you?
Sure.
Yeah.
You ever get that person who just wants
to like headlock you or something?
A guy asked me if he carried me.
Yeah,
I've heard that one.
Can I hold,
you know,
guys are always asking to choke me
because a lot of Jujitsu guys shows
like,
can I get you in a room naked?
But I don't trust anybody.
You can't just get my back like that.
So no,
I,
uh,
I don't get that as much does.
We'll ask all sorts of weird shit.
One guy asked me to bend over in front
of them in Louisville.
He goes,
will you bend over front?
And I'll make it like I'm spanking you.
I go,
what?
He goes,
I'm going to be behind you.
You're going to bend over and make a
killing on spanking you.
I go,
you really think that anybody would say
yes to that?
Any person you don't know,
say,
yeah,
go ahead and you'll,
I'll bend over like you're having sex
with me.
Like that kind of bend over.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Please.
How many times have you taken a photo
with a person after a Gig and you put
your,
the arm around and the smile and the
point to the face.
Maybe I've got a few poses a serious one
that happened.
Right?
So how many times have you like put your
arm around a couple of girls and then
one of them just grabs your cock riots
happened?
Yeah.
Yeah,
they just grab your cock and like just
sort of the fun of it happens because
honk on it like that because I don't
have to go further.
And you sort of get her.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like it is like,
thanks for that.
But imagine if a male did that to a
female act.
Just grabbed the tip.
Just grab her pussy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just went bang finger.
It would be like grabbing a guy's ass.
There'll be the same.
No,
no grabbing it goes out.
It's like grabbing a guy's ass.
Yeah,
I think if a girl grabs my dick,
I'm ready,
I'll automatically start fingering her
pussy.
Women that have this confidence and
normally
like a big jersey check we'd like for,
you know,
these aren't,
where you're like,
Ooh,
I always feel that grabbing a girl's ass
is way worse than a girl grabbing a guys
asked because it's not like she can rape
you.
A guy grabbed because I'm not a good
father.
You're a good fighter.
You think a lot of girls can rape you?
Oh yeah.
Monday,
plenty times happened several times.
I almost got raped last night.
Actually.
How dare you know,
I swear to God,
stopped down.
There was this girl that left the comedy
store.
Everyone.
There's tons of witnesses or this,
uh,
she comes up to me and she's talking to
me and she goes,
oh,
you're a bartender too?
And I'm like,
no,
I'm a bartender.
And then.
So she did,
she did a shot though and then she just
fucking comes in and tries to kiss me.
I'm like,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
And she's like,
I just got out of Rehab three days ago.
Uh,
you know,
I'm not supposed to be drinking right
now.
I was raped when I was a kid and just
started going off on like a million
things.
Now you're hooked.
So three days out of Rehab,
she's already drunk again.
She and your favorites yet?
No,
I,
I hid.
I was like,
I have to go to the bathroom and I ran
in the green room.
Main Room.
I'm still creeped out by as American
voice.
So I was thinking I was like,
this store is not going to have any
punch line.
You're not going to pay this off.
She's not going to rape you.
She didn't rape you,
man.
Some rape you at all?
No.
She tried to impose you.
Did was give you a kiss?
No,
no.
The whole time she was like trying to
like,
grab,
you know,
it's sexy isn't ripe is right.
Is it?
Yeah.
It's more than kissing.
She's not trying to throw me on my grind
raving,
but there's definitely a difference
between rape so easily.
I'm not saying real rape diet.
Right.
I just think it's way creepy.
Want to do grabs a girl's ass.
It's physical.
And you can't do anything about it.
And if I wanted to rape you,
I probably could get away with it if
there was nobody around.
That's what a guy saying when he grabs a
through a mind,
if I've ever like pinched to go,
that I haven't known quite wells asked
as they walked by.
I think if you're a person and you're,
you know,
you're like,
you don't even know this other person
and you just reach over and grab a girl
and squeeze it like that.
That's like a big violation.
That's like a big violation of space,
man.
Man.
Just tell us your sister or your
daughter.
Imagine if you watched someone do that
to your daughter.
Reach over and grab your daughter's ass.
That's what it.
Wow fucking violation.
That is.
And you know,
because to you it's not a guy's daughter
at some hot 20 year old,
but meanwhile behind her is her fucking
dad.
And you reach over and grab her ass.
That shit happens.
That's a creepy moment for people,
man.
When you realize what,
what it is,
when somebody just reaches over and
grabs you when you don't know them.
I don't have a daughter right now that's
kind of high.
If I imagined my sister or my daughter
being really hot,
some guy just grabbing it.
Slips have a child data.
So you can imagine grabbing my
daughter's fine.
Just whatever she wanted to look like.
I'm fine.
It was this imaginary Brian,
my daughter,
my daughter and your daughter now.
It closed down twice.
One day.
Her daughters are antigovernment talk
had to fill the,
uh,
my daughter has a touch of the accent
but not quite because he lived here,
but we take her on holidays.
She has a yeast infection.
I don't want your daughter near my
daughter
and we're going to lose sponsors.
We're going to lose viewers.
People are going to commit suicide.
You guys are having your artificial fake
fictional daughters engage in immoral
and illegal things.
I do.
It is upset now and she's cutting
herself.
She kinda,
I can't have that on my podcast.
She's a cottage.
He's not happy.
What is God?
When did that start?
When did cutting started?
Well,
but it's always,
when you meet that girl,
we,
you look at the forearms and you're
like,
oh,
she's going to be good in bed.
But yeah,
a buddy who found these marks on a girl,
he had dated her for awhile and then he
like saw one of her arms was like sliced
up and he goes,
it was a window into madness.
He said,
all the sudden I just went,
what the fuck is?
He goes,
and then I realized what the fuck.
He goes like,
and they were like,
lions,
man,
I can't believe I hadn't noticed him
before.
And he goes,
and all of a sudden I was like,
Holy Shit.
I went out with go long sleeves,
long sleeves,
and then after a few weeks and then I
saw it.
And because every time you got you got,
you had to be in the light light and it
was just these little,
like thousands of these little white
marks.
It doesn't.
Lindsay Lohan allegedly have do that.
I had a friend
who did it,
who she told me about.
It was quite a successful lady now.
But um,
and she explained it to me as you,
a,
you're depressed,
you blame yourself and everyone is
telling you that you shouldn't blame
yourself.
You just said,
why do you,
why do you hate yourself?
And you can never answer that question.
But if you cut yourself,
you're like,
that's why I hate myself because my fuck
up.
Who would do that to themselves?
Oh,
I should hate myself.
I've just cut myself.
Man.
It gives them the excuse to,
it's so amazing to me that we spend so
much time worrying about shit that's
going on overseas and these other
countries and so little time worrying
about how,
how many people are just getting raised
in some crazy fucked up way.
How many people are,
you know,
completely unqualified to be having
children.
Children are suffering under the
guidance and parental leadership or
these fuckheads like someone should
invest some something or something,
something that has got.
It's probably got to be done by
everybody all at once together.
There's no way like the government
could,
could fix the problem of stupidity and
craziness and abuse in this country.
There's no way.
I mean it,
but it at least make some sort of effort
to slow it down.
You know,
we will dump children.
It's almost always something fucked up,
happens to children and then they start
doing shit like cutting themselves or a
lot of other disturbing shit.
A lot of it is related to the sexual
abuse.
The guy from horter said,
whenever she gets involved,
if he goes to a house and people are
storing their shit or or shitting and
diapers and leaving them piled up,
it's always sexual abuse.
Fuck
crazy man.
We gotta fix that.
This has got to be a way to fix the
human.
Just fix the
what the fuck kids is really the best
way in it.
The best way is you've got kids ugly.
That's bad haircuts and horrible.
We've got to figure out a way to filter
every human being through some sort of
analysis.
Something that lets you know how fucked
up they are,
why,
you know,
if we could ever measure with like a
machine psychological fucked up,
you know,
if there's a machine you could,
you could talk all the shit you want,
but I'm gonna send you through a machine
and the machine comes out like,
oh no,
no,
this guy's fucking crazy.
That would be bad because in the
government would use that machine.
And so even though this talking
radically logically and normally we know
in the back of his head that he's,
he's a suicide.
They would cheat with a machine that
would cheat just like the voting
machines to Fox.
I just,
I've just bought a boat and going
through the mortgage process I found to
be very stressful.
The only reason why I mentioned this
because of the terrorist thing,
they asked to see.
They sent me down because I'm not,
I'm not a citizen.
So they asked to see what all my checks
were deposited,
my big money checks that are gone in a.
What were they and why did I get the
checks?
Right?
The CFI was a terrorist or at first I
have to be an idiot to,
but they were all like the chuckle hot
bananas like comedy related and I was
getting that one's comedy as well.
That one's also comedy.
Yes.
Nope.
That one's comedy.
Who's caroline?
She's comedy as well.
That's Hilarious,
but I just didn't it.
Yeah.
I don't know if Americans have to do
that,
but I was asked whether it was from to
fund terrorist for.
Wow.
That's fascinating.
What's the point?
I'd have to be the biggest fucking idiot
terrorists in the world to go go comedy
club comedy club now.
That one.
Our Credo.
That one's a bad one.
Like it's all comedy clubs.
Sometimes.
Training in the mountains of Turkey.
Yeah.
There's those training videos with the
dudes are running with like fucking the
rifles over their heads.
They have like the traditional afghany
outfits on really fascinating.
Faster.
Those,
those training footages of character,
terrorist training footages like you
bitches around shape,
like look at you.
What kind of fucking.
Oh No,
it is.
It is like a little league team trying
to play the Yankees.
Yeah,
exactly.
We have got your bats now look at this.
They're homemade ball bat.
We did not have a vote,
so we have got the rubber bands and what
tape and we have got the tape over and
over and it's commented in some Yuck.
One of the big UFC fighters got popped
for steroids this week.
Not Steroids,
but um,
he uh,
test Alistair Overeem,
tested his testosterone to estrogen was
14 to one.
Wow.
Yeah.
Which is normal.
A normal person is one to one and they
allow four to one in Nevada,
allow six to one because that used to be
the standard up until recently.
I should add all of these hair falling
out,
but he looks like a Goddamn Superhero.
He looks like a superhero in a movie.
Alistair Overeem,
not gay or I'm not getting anything but
the best.
So you're not talking about a man.
Anything right now.
There's nothing sexual but what I'm
saying.
But he's absolutely the most
unrealistically built human I've ever
seen.
Like if you see her for ignite type of
pr,
but the perfect size,
like the guy,
like he's smaller than like Lou
Ferrigno,
but ridiculously bad.
You see him,
you're like,
what?
They call them,
Uber like ridiculous built,
but he used to fight at two.
Oh,
five.
Used to be a much smaller,
much skinnier guy and he packed all this
weight and so they don't know what
caused this guy to test so high,
but it's most likely that he was a
supplementing his body's natural.
I thought most of them were probably on
some type of injection.
I would wonder what the real numbers
are,
man,
I wouldn't wonder,
but they're doing things like this now
and they're going to find out they're
gonna.
They're gonna catch a lot of people
because what they're doing is they're
doing it randomly,
like they show up for a press
conference.
No one told them they were going to be
drug tested and then boom,
all of a sudden the Nevada state
athletic commission is taking samples
from them,
so.
So they didn't have a chance to prepare
for it in the past.
What they would do is they would try to
cycle off of it,
but some people didn't and the people
that didn't fucked it up for everybody
else because then people start testing
positive and then people started like
the assert overturning.
A few fights have been overturned
because of it.
It should be a reality show.
Danish would make that like,
you know,
were they jumping in like,
all right,
we're going to test you now and then
that's a terrible idea.
That's a terrible idea.
I don't want to see that.
I think they're going to have to figure
out how many people are actually doing
this stuff.
You know?
I know for sure people have been caught
so for sure people are doing it,
you know,
and there's the estimations vary from
some people say half,
some people say almost all are doing
something.
Some people say it's a small percentage,
you know,
you would have to go fight camp to fight
camp and get guys on some sort of an
anonymous poll where they were honest
with you,
but knew that they weren't going to get
in trouble for it.
And even then,
I don't think people would be smart to
tell the truth.
It's just,
you know,
there's,
there's a,
there's a long standing tradition in
almost every sport where people take
things that make them better.
That's a fact.
And it's because they want to get better
at that sport and their body just can't
keep up the work pace.
Can't keep up the workload.
You know,
you can a guy get as big as mark mcgwire
got without steroids.
Yeah,
probably.
But that motherfucker better beaten ham
sandwiches over 15 minutes and doing
squats and dead lifts and,
and he's got not gonna have a lot of
time for baseball,
you know,
that's a goddamn power lifter physique.
And he got it by just just slamming that
needle in and pumping in that fucking
Superman Jewson and that's the way you
get good at baseball.
And that,
that felt like nothing to him.
He got up and I was fucking massive.
When he was the home run king,
when it was him and Sammy Sosa were
doing back and forth,
both of us looked like fucking
superheroes,
man.
Just giant muscles.
And they would go up and,
and these fucking balls would go flying
through the air into parking lots and
shit.
And everybody loved it,
but they didn't love how they did it.
And it's crazy that Mark Mcguire is the
only one who really kinda got off the
hook about it.
He,
he,
he admitted it to get a coaching job
like after he retired,
but he had shrunk down to a normal sized
person.
This is a very bongs now.
Looks like at the beginning of his
career.
Yeah.
He slimmed down.
Well,
you know,
he was probably doing a lot of crazy
shit in order to get better as he got
older.
You know,
that's when you're in your forties and
you're just smashing balls are like
Roger Clemens was just throwing crazy.
He,
you know,
he got better.
It's weird.
It's weird how you can dip like you're
eight.
It starts to show the signs of age and
then you just charge right back up.
And everybody's like,
well that's terrible.
He's cheating.
But I'm like,
God damn.
It looked easy.
It is though that there's something that
you can take that makes you better at
sports and isn't like being better at
sports,
isn't being more athletic,
isn't being more vibrant,
a sign of being healthy,
so shouldn't only be looking at this guy
and go,
isn't it amazing that modern science has
allowed barry bonds to actually get
better as he gets older and maybe I'll
allow him to take a little bit of this
and a little bit of that as long as he's
not getting too crazy because look
without that,
he was a very good baseball player
anyway.
But with that Jesus fucking Christ had
shit.
Get Fun at the Ballpark at Barry.
He seems fine,
you know,
I mean,
no one's stepping in to stop,
you know,
uh,
Ralphie may from eating too much.
There's no one from the government that
stepping in and the same,
the name of comedy and stopping him from
eating too much.
Is Steroids comedy though?
It's a personal writer ages real.
It doesn't.
My analogy was a terrible analogy.
Forget it.
It didn't make sense.
But what I was.
What I was trying to say was that I
guess it does make him way better at the
sport,
but I mean why wouldn't something that
makes you better at a sport be legal?
Shouldn't it be like used properly?
It seems to me that there's a lot of
people,
but as they
get older,
their arguments that it gives you cancer
or whatever,
but everything.
What the fuck doesn't give you cancer?
They can say anything gives you cancer
at this point.
You know,
I think a lot of people think cell
phones,
but there's no cases of it.
I don't think there's anybody's,
a brain tumor from a cell phone.
Have you heard that?
Rather?
I did.
Really.
There is people who've gotten brain
tumors,
but they're not doctors who were saying
this.
I gone on.
I think it's because
there's so much toxic shit in a.
In a person's environment,
it's so possible if you're not careful
with your diet and careful with your,
your health,
you know,
if you could be in the room,
you would live someplace where you don't
even realize it and the whole town is
getting poisoned by some chemical leak
or some shit that's happened a bunch of
times.
It's real common.
It's very difficult out there.
Jim Jefferies.
It's a change in this country.
It's very difficult.
More chemicals in the food.
Is it you find that a food taste
different here than in Australia?
No,
I find I find it harder in this country
you did to keep my weight off because
the chemicals on it and sort of the same
amount I find.
What is it different?
Like what kind of shit the most?
I think my beef in Australia is,
is just grasp it.
That isn't just like,
you know best for you.
Yeah.
That isn't just an option.
I think that's just what,
but if is in his strength and things
like Msg is just illegal where it's not
every trans fats illegal.
It's so ridiculous that that's not a
legal drink.
Guess what boys associate cigarettes and
you're both smokers yet mean cigarettes.
If neither one of you could be hooked on
cigarettes would thing about Msg is
different is I actually have a little
reaction.
I get damaged.
You feel a bit twitchy from eating it.
I know I've been in it so I,
when I go into a Chinese restaurant now
I have to go.
Do you have msg?
And they sometimes don't lie to me.
Right.
And how do you know,
do you just feel a little bit on age?
Just afterwards,
like my nerves are a bit,
you know,
what is it the,
what's the official medical I'm allergic
to?
It's,
it's a very,
it's a very sort of,
you know,
you get that like a,
like a tingly feeling in your jaw like
that.
What is that?
That happens to me.
Um,
but low sodium glutamate is a fucking
tenderizer or whatever.
It's not fun.
It was like a flavor enhancer.
Mike's mate softer and my vegetables
green.
Uh Huh.
You know what I mean?
It gives it color and mates.
But anyway,
it's illegal and was about trans fats
are illegal in the rest of these are
things you just don't fucking need.
Well,
we have a real problem in this country
where the giant corporations have
essentially completely bypassed the
whole system of government and just
control politicians.
I mean they just essentially just buying
people out.
And that's what's been done in this
country for the last few debt problem.
You know,
who knows?
The argument is forever.
But the point is right now,
the way things stand today,
there's a lot of shit that's bad for
you.
That's legal.
There's a lot of shit.
There's a lot of God damn pain killers
that are fucking terribly addictive.
And they were passing them out like
cookies.
There's a lot of shit in this country
that's fucked up.
It's,
you know,
it's a,
it's a big message.
And how know fucking fix this.
You know,
what'd you do?
Jim?
Jefferies as an outsider,
why would I do what to fix America?
Yeah.
Oh,
I bring in healthcare.
I'm a big believer in healthcare and
healthcare will do it.
Healthcare,
I believe is essential in a,
in a,
in a modern society.
I can't listen to anymore.
I've lived in Britain whether health is
good and everything in Australia with
the healthcare is great.
And the arguments that sort of
republican and on top like right,
yeah,
where they go I won't have as good
healthcare and,
and what about my great healthcare I
have now and then I'll have you don't
have,
you can still get private healthcare
cover.
This is what people don't get.
You can still get the good private stuff
but you have an ailment and not yet.
You will never know the price of one of
your ailments.
Right.
That's the whole thing.
So,
so at the moment I,
a couple of moles,
I went back because I had some cancerous
moles in my back cut out right there.
The doctor has with the terminologies is
like it's $4,800
to this.
I was thinking that can't fucking be
$4,100
to do it.
Right.
So I went and checked with another
total.
I'm dermatologist and I said 500 bucks
right now if I just had.
What happens with a private health care
cover in Britain,
you get everyone gets the same doctors,
but your.
If you're just using public health k you
put on a waiting list so they might look
at your mall and go,
all right you two months before you can
get that cut out,
right.
Where if you have the private stuff on
top,
you guys strike to the beginning of the
list,
but I never know how much I'm paying or
how much they are charging or whatever.
So it's a regulated a lot better.
I've have been here.
It feels like getting quotes from
fucking mechanic.
Yeah,
it's totally like that.
Especially dentist out here are the
worst.
Like dentist almost are trying to
upgrade you with certain things that you
paused.
You pretty much.
Don't you think you need a feeling here
because they wanted a few because this
is fucking bullshit.
Yeah.
My Dad's trying to give me an
invisalign.
Yeah.
Mine was trying to give me a little bit
of crooked teeth.
Bottom couple of crooked like fuck that
bitch visit lot.
Oh,
it's like invisible braces.
You're going to get braces.
You better get just regular braces.
Some dudes got braces and it helped them
a lot like frank shamrock operations,
but his teeth were fucked up.
My teeth are not that far.
Like Tom Cruise did it like a few years
ago,
like five years ago.
Yeah.
It was always you take before.
I don't remember ever looking at his
teeth like,
oh,
Tom's fucked.
I don't know.
He's.
He's probably crazy.
If you're famous,
you must be completely out of your
fucking mind.
How do you be Tom Cruise?
I can't go anywhere in the world that
someone known who he is and yet he's in
a crazy cult organization and yet
there's rumors of him being gay.
I mean,
you want to talk about like a dark
circle of secrets.
If Tom Cruise really is gay,
that would be the ultimate reality show.
It's
a room of people just never shut up and
even.
And I will say even people in the
industry.
Yeah.
Oh Dude,
I've,
I've heard it from so many people that
I've heard people say that they thought
it was him and Travolta and.
Yeah,
exactly.
Especially Travolta Travolta.
I think they caught him with a photo
kissing that guy getting on the plane.
Yeah.
Who was the nanny and come on man.
You know,
I mean maybe this is just weird like
that.
He could just be.
But there's a lot of people that say
they've had sex with him and he's just
whatever,
man.
Let the guy be gay who gives a shit.
Yeah.
I didn't give a shit.
I would be happier for the guy if he
would just come out.
You know,
nobody cares.
This goddamn John Travolta.
People love him.
They love him from Saturday night fever
from pulp fiction.
They would.
We personally know.
Of course we not going to say,
hey,
we personally know comedians who are gay
who keep it under wraps as sad as shit
ever.
And I always think comics,
especially women,
to be the most honest of them all.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know what I mean?
We're not playing characters.
We're playing ourselves.
I feel like.
And then some of them were like MDF.
No.
Here's my.
I'm going to tell you.
Tell me.
You tell me if you agree.
I find that the ones that keep it in the
closet,
they always have a problem with
creativity.
They always have a problem with coming
up with new material because uh,
they're not,
they're not really alive in their own
life,
like free and open and unrestricted,
so it's more difficult for them to come
up with material and especially because
they can't draw in real life
experiences,
the gay stuff.
So they're like really like in this
weird pocket of bullshit where they,
they're the ones that a guy that you're
not even allowed to say it to them.
And then there's the ones with the
comedy community,
we can all say the president's game.
Right,
right,
right.
Um,
but you know,
there's a fairly famous older black
gentleman who he gets angry if you.
Oh yeah,
he'll get very mad.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
He's old school.
He'll fight you fight you.
You're like,
there's,
there's more than one of those.
By the way,
John,
I could have been talking about either
one of them.
I think it might be harder in the black
community and that might be very
ignorant to me to sign up.
I think it might be harder in the black
community of that generation.
I'd be willing to guess.
Yes.
I don't know or yeah,
I don't know,
but I think if I had a time machine,
I don't think I'd go back in time to the
black community,
that general.
Remember an episode of Good Times where
they were gay,
buried like Diana mileage.
God,
I don't know.
Maybe it would suck though.
Dom irrera so fucking funny.
He said,
I wish I was gay just so I could come
out and he's been.
He really is that guy.
He does not give a fuck.
Like he's not pretending to knock.
He really doesn't give a fuck.
So when he says something,
I wish I was gay just so I could come
out.
It's like extra funny.
It is like an extra little treat they
get in life.
The color coming out.
Yeah.
And have everybody embrace you.
We love you for your personality.
We don't care.
I'd love to have people ring me up one
day and go,
I still love you.
Just there's no reason.
People who,
people who haven't said they loved me
ever.
Just to say they still love me once.
That would be fucking awesome.
Yeah.
I think in the people that you lose,
if you.
If you're a gay guy and he came out of
the closet,
do you really want that guy?
No,
I don't want them to see.
Then you get the double and so you lose
a Granddad,
but then a few years later he's like,
you know what?
I don't want to be back in your life
again,
and then you get another little present
on top if your Granddad,
but then what if he just talks about it
while you're fishing last week,
tell your grandpa fucking freak.
You can't just be with a girl.
Is it really that bad?
Girls are pretty and all of a sudden
you're stuck on a boat when he angry.
GRANDPA has a remarkable like truth that
the girls are very pretty.
He is right.
You know a lot of them are.
That's the confusing thing about
homosexuality.
What are they thinking?
Well,
the confused aren't heterosexual.
I will fight for their right to think
that way,
but I'll never understand it.
You can feel about heterosexuality is
what the fuck the girl seeing us.
I don't understand why anyone's fucking
men on either side.
No one should be fucking men.
Yeah.
It doesn't look like fun to me.
Especially when you get into weird shit
that you'll never understand.
Like girls will want to be choked.
Like can you even relate to that?
Wait a contortionist last night on the
night show and she can put her leg up
here and she likes to be choked.
Well fucking like,
wow,
that's crazy.
Selects a trailer.
So triangle or puts her leg over her
shoulders.
Does she lock it up?
Whoa.
She triangles herself.
That's good.
Because then because you chose to go and
then you get that bit where their eyes
just rolled back a bit and you've got
to.
Oh,
trying to think if I could triangle
myself.
I don't need to see it.
Man.
Shit.
I'm pretty flexible in her legs up and
put it behind her back.
Even though you're flexible.
I don't think your legs are long enough,
is longer than a miles like
proportionate.
Well not only that,
there's also the body's thinner so you
can compress it more and when you got
body mass it's makes it more difficult
to flatten out.
Sure.
But you'd have to be in some serious
flexible.
So she chokes herself and then what
happens?
She,
she was just showing us like what were
her favorite things?
While she's getting fucked,
she was telling you that,
wow,
that's a green lights on.
That girl wants to fuck with her.
Did they're both.
They do burlesque here in Los Angeles.
Native is letting you know if a storm,
how she look,
what position she likes to be in when
she gets extremely violent.
How I came up to that.
Yeah.
Do you need to aid?
I like a loyal soldier.
You need to jump on that girl.
Please help someone.
Someone.
Someone else.
Good for her.
What a good kid.
What a lucky fella.
That lad.
He lucked out.
She's like this close this close from
being able to eat her pussy.
I've seen girls eat their own person.
I have to do that.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
I've cut it out first.
Defeated Jeffrey's again,
Scott.
I told you about it.
I could touch the tip of my tongue.
I have to Piss so bad.
Please talk.
We're actually not going to get going
soon.
Should we?
Should we wrap up?
Let me Piss.
No rabbit.
Okay.
I could.
I could touch the tip of my penis with
my tongue,
but once I do it and I'm like,
this is the gas thing is ridiculous.
It's like,
why would we want to do that?
It's yeah.
I,
I've never been able to do that,
but I don't think I'd even.
I think you would do it once
just to have the.
Yeah,
it was like an elbow pretty much.
It was like an elbow,
but like taste like and felt like an
elbow on your tongue.
I can't.
I can't touch my elbow with my tongue.
Lose elbows.
Just thinking.
Well,
I guess I could.
Yeah,
I could do.
Hey.
Hey,
you can't.
No,
no,
no.
You can't.
You can't make your.
Must have links to other girls.
I've probably never let a couple of
girls.
So the top of your cock fights like a
girl's elbow?
Yeah.
That's good.
Now every time I look at girl fell,
but I'm going to feel like I'm sucking a
cock.
You have your own podcast podcast called
talking shit on itunes.
Always asked and we have bad we had.
He's always asking or telling me about
how it is.
Always take that into your shit.
Did they stop?
Did they back off?
At the moment?
We're on,
but we never get on your note worthy or
anything like that.
We never get any
little thing,
but that's okay.
You ever thought about just changing the
name?
The eddies very attached to it.
It's a,
you know,
I'm not too bothered changing that in
the podcast because Archie's took us
down a couple of times.
So yeah.
What would you call it?
We're at the moment,
it's just,
it's still talking shit,
but we just moved the s over to talking.
So it's talkings hit.
Oh,
I see that with pepsis pace Pepsi space
program.
Oh,
talkings hit.
That's not bad.
That's not.
That's actually good.
That's not bad.
Yeah.
Leave it there.
Everybody has a fucking says it's weird
and it can't have shit on itunes.
Really rarely,
but what could be in the podcast,
anything could offend someone to see the
word Shit.
You know,
what kind of clientele you did say that
Mark Marin has wtf everyone knows what
that means,
you know,
like as long as it's abbreviated.
But I always find those.
How insulting it is.
Like when you get the sweater with,
it's made out of question marks and
symbols,
you know,
it gets me freaking.
This freaking guy pulls this freaking
car and someone can do that in front of
kids that can do that in front of old
people.
You could say freaking in front of him,
but I've seen it.
It's like,
to me it's just a lot of kids
translating it.
It's silly.
Freaking the silly.
You're saying,
fuck it.
You're saying fucking this fucking guy
cut me off.
You're saying that,
but you're saying it to me in this weird
reserved way by saying freaking the RH,
the have a tech fic feck you fucking
idiot.
You fucking chicken vic,
vic,
vic.
Well,
you know,
and they had on CNN,
they,
they said fucking over and over and over
again because they're playing back this
tape from the Zimmerman Guy,
the nine slash 11 called the guy who
supposedly he did kill that Trayvon
Martin Kid.
Right,
right,
right.
Well,
they were wondering whether or not he
said he was on.
They recorded his phone call with the
nine slash 11 guy.
They were wondering whether he said
fucking coon.
So they're playing over and over and
over.
They bring in all these like special
enhancements at the end,
they believe you saying fucking cold
because it was raining and cold that day
in Florida,
but the minute they spent like 15
minutes playing this back and forth
talking about it and Wolf Blitzer
saying,
so now ladies and gentlemen,
if you have kids,
please,
I'd like you to ask him to leave the
room right now.
You're going to hear some very strong
language.
We have brought in a voice expert who
has analyzed Mr Zimmerman's tone and any
plays it back fucking comes fucking
Koons fucking coons.
And then they have brought in a new guy.
It's really kind of fucked up that they
did this this way because then they
brought in like a new recording and they
said,
well,
now in this new recording you believe
that it's not that correct,
and the guy goes,
yes.
When we play it back now it says,
fucking cold.
You hear the guy say fucking cultural.
You already had that information,
but you played all this other shit where
it's at fucking coon fucking coon.
You knew that's not what he said.
He drew people in and kept me listening.
Tricking me with your old information.
You played back your old information to
rope people in you fucking whoever did
that as dirty.
That's a dirty move.
Fucking because I was hearing that guy.
My opinion of them as I was driving my
opinion changed.
I'm here fucking coon.
I'm like,
whoa.
He's calling fucking coon.
Really?
Like,
wow,
this motherfucker's on phone.
He's on nine slash 11 and he's just
calling this kid a fucking coon,
eh?
This is what they had me believing.
And then I'm like,
wow.
That was probably a piece of shit.
And then I hear my fucking cold.
Like,
oh,
he's kind of a bitch,
kind of a whiner,
which makes sense in the first place if
you know,
if it ended up.
His story is true.
If the 17 year old kids on top of him
beating him up.
All right.
I also have to urinate.
Dude.
Let's get this fucking thing over with.
If you look for Jim on twitter,
it's Jeff or jeffery j e s,
s I fucked up and tweeted earlier.
There's another guy who impersonates me
and spending some fake ass bitch.
There's a lot of them out there.
Folks.
Don't be one.
You have the power to control your right
life,
right Jim,
you certainly can give it a go.
Give it a go.
Check out their podcast.
Check out the desk squad where we will
be doing an ice house chronicles
tomorrow night,
like tonight,
tonight.
What's today?
Friday now.
Oh Shit.
We got to do another podcast moments
from now.
By the time you hear this,
if you're in your car,
it sort of taken place.
The only way to hear it though is to go
to desk squad on itunes
and subscribe and there's a bunch of
other podcasts and they're all of them
at this point in time.
Over money.
You're happy with all of them.
I'm really happy with the new ones with
a Dana d,
airman,
and uh,
Ryan Keeley.
Oh,
I didn't know mf said comic book one.
And then last night we started sex squad
backup with people.
Are you going to do that other girl?
The girls still call it sex squad.
Okay.
Where's?
She goes,
oh,
come on Brian.
You confused the shit out of people.
You should be been confusing the shit
out of people.
I say.
I say,
you let them have that.
I say you'd be a bigger,
bigger,
better man.
It has the word squad in it.
It wasn't her show.
A lot of people.
I didn't really want to talk about this,
but let's talk about this real quick.
I go to somebody and be like,
Hey,
I want to do a show on my podcast.
It's a sex based podcasts and I'm ready
to call it sex to cast.
And then Jaden coil goes,
why don't you just call it sex squad?
I'm like,
okay,
yeah,
that makes sense.
And then I'm like,
Hey,
do you want to come on the show and
empty when it come on the show somebody
else and somebody else.
And then they just kind of stopped
talking to me like,
Hey,
we're doing this show.
Listen,
I completely agree with you on that.
They should have said something to you
and that's not cool for them to leave
and take name.
But all I'm saying is let them know what
do you care?
You can have another name.
They could take another name.
You know why?
Because I created a show.
I was co hosted the show.
I paid for the show.
I did the show and it was not their show
to begin with.
They weren't,
there were people on the show and I
understand,
but they wanted to do it on the road.
So you should have changed the name,
but why wouldn't you just give a this?
I don't give a fuck.
You know,
Okay.
I would just say that you know,
the,
the girl,
you're pretty much telling me or like
right now,
don't use that Avatar on facebook.
No,
that's not what I'm saying.
Yes.
You are saying,
look,
they,
that you were going to do this show with
them.
You're not going to do it anymore.
You're going to do another one.
It was supposed to not be with them 100
percent.
It was supposed to be other people on
the show.
It was them.
Sometimes they kind of plotted on the
ship.
Do you only do it with them?
Yeah,
but Ryan Keeley and a couple other
people were.
We're supposed to be on the show at
points of time,
but they kind of talked me out of it
type stuff.
Okay.
But they.
So they did talk you out of it though
and all the episodes they did.
Where would just them no one time they
had already should fear,
but I was the host of the show.
Okay.
I'm the one that was like,
hey,
this is brian coming here from ice
house.
We're here again.
What's up?
Jaded.
But in all fairness,
in all fairness,
and I'm on your side for this because
first of all,
you can't just take a guy's show if he's
the host of it and you don't know what
you tell them and run somewhere else.
But didn't that Jayden Coal Guy didn't?
She actually just told you exactly what
happened.
I said I wanted to do a podcast.
It was called sex and she goes,
you should call it sex squad because
it's on the death squad podcasts.
Now I heard that,
but didn't.
That's her name.
Then she invented it.
She could do whatever she wants.
I'm the one that fucking used it and
made paid for it and made a podcast with
it.
Getting crazy again.
So without a debt,
without me creating death or mi using
desk squad,
her knowing death squad,
would she have ever used the word quad
squad?
Who knows?
Exactly.
So she did is she took the half of 50
percent of it for me.
But isn't there other sex squads online?
There's tons of sex squad.
I didn't create sex on top in Anthony
Nolan or,
or whatever.
It's,
you know,
it's,
there's actually another company that
makes it a sexual harassment videos for
fucking school,
so it's not even something that's
original.
Anyway,
I don't do it,
but all I'm saying is,
look,
she shouldn't take it for sure.
No,
no,
no.
I didn't take it.
I can fucking sit here and show you
about 50 text messages that I got from
Jayden.
Okay.
Let's wait.
Wait,
I could do that,
but I didn't.
But you know what she did?
She went on her website and blogs a bad
fucking posted shit about.
I could say show the shit that shit.
Don't you of feel bad that that's her.
That's what she's doing.
Don't you kind of feel bad.
I feel bad about this whole situation.
I feel bad.
But you know what?
They're not using the sex squad name
they had.
They started the first Tuesday.
Show that they're calling it something
like sex squid or it's just spell it.
All right,
let's let them do whatever the fuck they
want.
I don't give a shit what I said.
It's why don't you please not use the
word squad because it confuses a show
that we already started with sex.
Let me just clarify one thing.
I don't ever like to get as worked up
about a stupid name as you just did.
Well,
I don't like to get bashed on somebody.
You.
You're not getting bashed by a balanced
person.
I certainly would,
but you could have avoided this conflict
with her if she wants to do things and
take that elsewhere.
You tell him no,
but I thought jd is a good friend of
mine.
She didn't fucking say one word to me.
She didn't make one call.
They said that they get returned phone
calls and stuff.
They made shit up about me.
They can fucking eat it depths.
Unfortunate,
but that's called fucking slander and I
didn't even fucking do shit.
All these fucking making shit up mouth.
Don't have that kind of power over you,
man.
Just cut them loose.
Cut them loose in life.
Don't.
Don't hate on him.
Anyways,
the new.
The new.
Okay.
I'm glad we called them the new sex
squad.
How about that?
The new sex club review,
but sex squad with Dana dear to,
to one data,
her giant.
But remember once you told her she has a
giant but she is.
Listen man,
I don't like you can see and you get all
worked up like getting A.
I don't like lies talking shit on me and
slander.
I understand.
If they would've just came to me and be
like,
Hey,
can we do this podcast somewhere else?
And be like,
you know what?
Okay,
what didn't you like about the podcasts?
You listen,
let's end this shit.
Stupid Shit.
Alright folks,
fucking goddamn shows over.
Jim Jefferies show starts in about 10
minutes.
He's not even gonna.
Make it there on time and we've kept him
in a bit late.
But some nonsense arguments.
Uh,
I,
you,
you both in the right.
Jim,
Jefferies,
you're a powerful individual.
Hilarious standup comic.
Take you very much for being on the
show.
Thank you to the flashlight.
You know what to do.
Go to the fleshlight.
Entering the Code Day Brogan.
Save yourself 15 percent.
Oh Shit,
I said it.
You heard it.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t and
use the code name Rogan to pickup your
shroom tech,
your Alpha brain,
your shroom tech immune or your fight.
What?
We've got a lot of shit coming up.
We've got kettle bells coming out to
son.
See you,
dirty freaks using and Rogan save 10
percent and we will see you guys next
week.
Lots of fun shit next week.
Alright,
bye.
Surprises us.